hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
this is an episode I've wanted to record
for several years I've been asked many
times dozens of times possibly hundreds
of times about ketamine and this is
intended to be the most comprehensive
in-depth
coverage of ketamine in the podcast
space it is intended to be your One-Stop
shopping or at least your first stop in
all things ketamine we get deep in the
weeds so if you get lost at any point or
start to drift because it's technical
just wait two to five minutes and we
almost always explain things or shift
gears and the reason also that I wanted
to do this episode is that I know
friends who have averted suicide using
supervised ketamine and that is reason
enough for me to want to put this
together my guest today is the
incredible John Crystal Dr John crystal
is the Robert L McNeil Jr professor of
translational research professor of
Psychiatry neuroscience and psychology
chair of the Department of Psychiatry at
Yale University and the chief of
Psychiatry and Behavioral Health at Yale
New Haven Hospital Dr crystal is a
leading expert in the areas of
alcoholism post-traumatic stress
disorder schizophrenia and depression
his work links psychopharmacology
neuroimaging molecular genetics and
computational Neuroscience to study the
neurobiology and treatment of these
disorders and he is very fluent
well-versed in many other things but he
is best known for leading the discovery
of the rapid antidepressant effects of
ketamine in depressed patients he
co-directs the Yale Center for Clinical
investigation ctsa niaa Center for
translational Neuroscience of alcoholism
and clinical Neuroscience division of
the national Center for PTSD Dr crystal
is a member of the U.S National Academy
of Medicine co-director of the
Neuroscience Forum of the U.S national
academies of Sciences engineering and
Medicine fellow of the American
Association for the advancement of
Science and editor of biological
Psychiatry one of the most selective and
highly cited journals in the field of
psychiatric Neuroscience he's the
co-founder and chief scientific officer
of Freedom biosciences which you can
find at freedombio.com a clinical stage
biotechnology platform developing Next
Generation ketamine and psychedelic
Therapeutics that just recently emerged
from stealth in August of 2020 E2 one
very important disclaimer I'm not a
doctor nor do I play one on the internet
none of the content in this podcast
constitutes medical advice or should be
construed as a recommendation to use
ketamine or psychedelics there are
psychological physical and sometimes
legal risks with such usage you have to
be smart you have to consult experts
please consult your doctor before
considering anything we discussed in
this episode and with all of that said
please enjoy my very in-depth very
wide-ranging very nuanced and I give
that credit to Dr Crystal conversation
with Dr John Crystal
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Dr Crystal it is good to see you again
thank you for making the time for this
conversation I really appreciate it
well my pleasure and I thought we would
start with the personal we're going to
get into the scientific I've been
looking forward to this conversation for
a long time as I mentioned to you before
recording because I I really think this
will be an incredible resource for
people but I'd like to begin with some
of your personal history could you
please describe
for people listening in for me your
father and some of his bio and history
my father was a psychiatrist and
psychoanalyst named Henry Crystal and he
passed away a number of years ago
he was born in the town of sosnovies in
Poland in 1925 and
at the age of 14.
was
captured
by the Nazis who were rounding up the
Jews in his area of Poland and sent
through a series of concentration camps
importantly you know names people would
probably recognize would be Auschwitz
Saxon house and buchenwald and he
survived
the concentration camps
and he was the only member of his family
to survive so
he was captured at the age of 14 and by
1718 when he came out of the out of the
camps was
alone in the world essentially
he went to school attained some
schooling in Germany and then came to
the United States
where he had an aunt
who put him up and and I grew up with
stories of him sleeping in the cellar of
her convenience store around the pickle
jars that would spontaneously explode
during the night because
for whatever reason they were very
potent and uh he was able to get a
scholarship to Wayne State University
for college and then another scholarship
to go to medical school
and you know along the way he
mastered English and uh you know settled
into the United States
and he became
very powerfully influenced
by
the chairman of the Department of
Psychiatry at Wayne State University
whose name was John Dorsey who had been
analyzed by Freud
whose view of of psychiatry
was had to do with people
I'm embracing all aspects of themselves
and becoming kind of integrated human
beings and
and that that was a path
towards both a healthy life and a
fulfilling life
which was an idea that my father also
not only embraced in his work but
embraced in in his life
and ironically
my name is John j o h n
which is
not commonly the name given to Jewish
children
who often name Jonathan instead but I'm
called John because I'm named after
Dr Dorsey who is Irish so my dad became
a psychiatrist
and in his work
evaluated
people who survived the Holocaust for
reparations to the German government
and
this was both an incredibly meaningful
task but also one that was extremely
challenging for many reasons one is that
he had to relive his own traumas in the
process of working with the more than a
thousand people that he evaluated
for reparations from the German
government for their traumas and the
second thing was that he was in a nearly
impossible position which was
that he was
evaluating people for psychological
damages related to their Holocaust
experience
and this was in the in the 1950s 1960s
almost 30 years 20 years before the
diagnosis of post-traumatic stress
disorder existed
and what happened was that he and a
colleague of his his
Bill Nederland from New York they
developed this idea of Survivor syndrome
of the psychological consequences of
trauma that became one of the
cornerstones along with the work of many
others such as Robert J Lipton for what
became the diagnosis of post-traumatic
stress disorder and his work
throughout his career
about the trying to understand the roots
of of resilience and vulnerability and
to develop treatments that would help
people to manage the impact of
psychological traumas that was his life
work and and
profoundly inspiring for me I've always
felt that there was no challenge that I
could ever face
no obstacle that I could ever meet that
was would ever match the challenges that
my father's father faced in his life
and the kind of
perspective that my dad brought to his
own
life challenges his the way that he
survived in the concentration camps
of recognizing and seizing opportunities
that arose for him
and and realizing what was happening and
and seizing these kinds of opportunities
which enabled him to survive
were also profound life lessons
that in
pursuing what one
was working on that you had to
get outside of the constraints that the
environment
placed on you and recognize the nascent
opportunities out there
no matter how out of the box and how
unorthodox they were in order to
have a real impact that was a key to my
father's survival but it was also a key
for the way my father turned this
process of
evaluating people for disability
pensions
turn that into the foundation for
helping to open up the field of of
post-traumatic stress disorder and have
a huge positive impact so I have no
doubt that my father's
life experience and the way that he
developed his career profoundly
impacted me and my thinking and the
things that I I thought were important
and what I ended up pursuing and the way
that I'm pursuing them the other thing
about my father was he was profoundly
curious and would read religions he
would read history he would read
Neuroscience he would read philosophy he
would pursue almost any field that that
he thought had any relevance
to what he was thinking about and that
perspective also was normally incredibly
impactful for me and has influenced the
way I approach it everything that I do
thank you for sharing that John and it's
uh
part of the fabric of
who you are also these stories and I had
no idea of this background of course I
mean one of the great gifts that I get
from these conversations is the excuse
to do what would otherwise be very
creepy in terms of due diligence on my
friends or people that I know and I'd
love to ask you a bit more about your
father and I'm pulling from in this case
a
New York Times piece which I believe was
you know effectively
upon your father's passing and
I'll just read a short section here that
will lead into the question so he is as
your father attributed the survival of
some inmates to an almost childlike
belief in their own indomitability and
then the quote is from your father I
feel that quote unquote healthy
infantile omnipotence is the most
important asset for dealing with life's
stresses and potential trauma Dr Crystal
wrote in a chapter he contributed to
living with Terror working with trauma a
clinician's handbook
and I'll shorten this to end the quote
with it is an emotional mainspring of
extraordinary reserves it provides a
profound unshakable conviction of one's
invulnerability
is that something that he ever discussed
with you or fostered in you I would love
to to hear anything that comes to mind
first I want to reassure you that
he was like a normal person and so like
he would never talk about the omnipotent
uh interjected object at the dining room
table right you can imagine people have
all kinds of ideas about what
psychoanalysts talk about over dinner
and mostly it was just bread and butter
things the second thing is that he
believed that the parent-child
interaction was
fundamental to all human resilience
and in that kind of
nurturing supportive interaction
lay the root of optimism
and having a sense that no matter
what is happening around you that
there's still the possibility that
things will work out okay
is an enormous gift that comes out of
this kind of nurturing developmental
experience
and so much of what he dealt with in
treating people who had been traumatized
in psychoanalysis and in psychotherapy
was the way
that
early life traumas
disrupt that and create a feeling not of
optimism and the potential for things to
work out but the opposite that in the
expectation that the world is a
dangerous threatening place and that
failure lurks around the corner and so
creating the very constraints on
creativity and motivation deadening hope
deadening creativity constraining
opportunities that people are putting
this cage on themselves
as a consequence of
the disruption of
the sense of
safety and possibility that is
a natural byproduct of a nurturing
childhood experience
well let's use that as a
perfect leaping point to
hop into some of the the salt and bread
the meat and potatoes
of some of the subjects that we'll cover
because looking at your bio just as an
example right Dr Crystal's leading
expert in areas of alcoholism
post-traumatic stress disorder
schizophrenia depression it sounds like
a roll call for one of my family
reunions and
and
I certainly if people are not aware I'll
just provide a little context
have experienced chronic
or what we call it repeated but also a
very severe depression throughout my
life it appears to be hereditary
and as you mentioned
there are people for whom despair
instead of Hope is a default setting or
feels like a default setting and there
can be say a catalyzing event where in
my lived experience there might be a
situation that provokes or I should say
that I allow to provoke
a feeling of Despair hopelessness and
then I'm able to observe the mindset and
objectively perhaps think this shouldn't
bother me so much this is a failure of
imagination there are friends of mine
people I know who would deal with this
with complete Equanimity and then
there's hopelessness about ever-changing
the mindset and I think that is the
scariest part
so perhaps we could begin with just a
brief
discussion doesn't have to be brief
about depression and perhaps what people
underestimate don't appreciate about
depression what you have
come to realize perhaps as a clinician
over many decades just to set the table
as it were for our discussion of
different treatments comparisons
ketamine Etc
I think that people
think that depression is like having a
bad day
and
everybody's had a bad day
and everybody's had a few bad days
and
and I think
that some of the confusion about
depression
has to do with the way in which we use
throw depression around as a term like
I spilled my coffee and I'm depressed
about that now yeah that is a
disappointment right but that kind of
experience isn't what we're talking
about when we talk about depression when
we talk about depression is more about
the experience that you're talking about
the way that depression can be a
pervasive
motive being that invades every aspect
of one's life and experience of the
world it affects the pattern of your
thinking in other words instead of as
you say instead of seeing the world as a
mixture of risk and opportunity
you see the negative in everything that
you engage
it affects the way you make judgments
instead of being able to make judgments
based on reasonable risk reward kinds of
decisions everything's colored by the
negativity
what people often don't appreciate about
depression is that it goes beyond
sadness for many people it can be a
complete
blunting of emotional experience and
people describe sometimes the loss of
feeling
one of the people that we treated with
ketamine said that she was just amazed
to have feelings again after her
depression began to lift people often
describe feeling blue when they're
depressed because the contrasts in the
world their visual experience of the
world is as if the the normal contrasts
are blunted and and colors seem duller
and and
things that are exciting and rewarding
seem blander and
a kind of sapping of lice essence
this kind of depression is associated
with a loss of energy a loss of
concentration difficulty sleeping waking
up early in the morning tossing and
turning in difficulty relaxing and
feeling comfortable being overcome with
pervasive
intrusive recurring thoughts on negative
things like
I'm a terrible person I let people down
over and over and over ruminating on
these negative
horrible ideas and
I mentioned a sapping of energy
loss of appetite decreased interest in
activities a kind of withdrawal this
state was deemed by the Greek
Hippocratic doctors as
as a kind of fundamental negative mode
of being that they thought was connected
to black bile which in Greek
had the name melon for black collia for
bile and then has been known as
Melancholia or black melancholic
depression ever since and there's
another kind of depression that we also
see which is people who have the
capacity
to see good and bad but who cannot
constrain the way in which they react so
something good happens they can
react in a normal way to it but
something bad happens to them and they
spiral downward in a very negative way
out of beyond their control to Despair
and hopelessness and extreme distress
that is not the typical profile of
traditional melancholic depression but
as a kind of reactive depression so that
there are one of the things that we
appreciate about depression is that can
be a very heterogeneous things that
there's a whole array of different kinds
of depression
and we're just at the early stages of
sorting that out but one thing that's
really important
for people to understand that they often
don't understand is the medical part of
depression and when I say medical part
is that that we understand
yes medical depression is a state of
emotional experience and yes it's a
altered way of brain function
but it's a brain function of an embodied
brain in other words depression is a
state that affects your entire body
medical factors like inflammatory
processes in the body related to obesity
cardiac disease arthritis
asthma a variety of things that cause
inflammation in the body increase your
risk for depression
and if you have depression it makes
inflammation worse
and that means it makes all of those
medical illnesses where inflammation is
a process worse and so that if you have
untreated depression on average
it shortens your life not by Suicide
it still shortens your life by about
five years and if you have depression in
the context of medical illnesses it
makes the medical outcomes worse not
only the psychological outcomes but the
medical outcomes worse So Meta
depression is a disorder of the spirit
if you will the brain but also the whole
body and and that's one of the reasons
why number one
it's one of the most disabling
conditions that we have in the world
and two it's from a medical point of
view it's also urgently important that
people are treating their depression
one thing you and I spoke about a little
bit before recording that I'd love for
you to touch on is
perhaps the
the high frequency with which you have
observed partial recovery and not full
recovery or partial treatment and not
full treatment perhaps if if you could
just speak to that
so Psychiatry has struggled with what to
do with partial response and
non-response for all psychiatric
disorders and I'm embarrassed to say
that there is a strain of a history in
psychiatry
when patients didn't get better
that they'd blame the patient
in other words they would say things
like well that patient wasn't adequately
engaged in treatment they didn't engage
in Psychotherapy they weren't a good
Psychotherapy candidate they didn't blah
blah blah and while it's true that
people engage in treatment with varying
levels of motivation and understanding
and things like that
we would never say for a heart attack
for heart disease well you know the they
had a heart attack but they you know
they weren't very motivated to be in
treatment so what could we do we would
never say that we would always say
well let's look at the illness let's try
to optimize the treatment and if people
aren't responding let's do something
about that that the field of Psychiatry
hasn't always taken ownership
for the fact that our our treatments
don't always work as effectively as we'd
like them to be now there are some
underlying reasons why that tends to
happen a little bit more in Psychiatry
than in some other aspects of Medicine
one of them is that there's just not
inadequate support for Psychiatry mental
health treatment generally so it's a
scarce resource and people often
essentially take what they can get and
that speaks to the inadequacy of our
national approach to making sure that
people have access to effective Health
Care a second thing is we don't measure
outcomes in clinical practice in any
kind of routine way in other words
if you have a heart attack
then you get scans and they measure the
EKG the electrical activity of the heart
maybe you have a stress test maybe you
have an echocardiogram to measure the
ability of your heart to contract well
where are those tests in psychiatry
those tests to the extent that we have
them are basically brief questionnaires
that people can complete to give us some
semi-quantitative idea about how people
are doing but those outcome measures
aren't routinely applied in clinical
practice and so that as a field
when we look at our Health Care Systems
there's no data on outcomes for the
clinical interventions or much less data
on outcomes some Healthcare systems like
the VA have started to embed clinical
ratings into clinical care but it's not
a situation where the field has been
held accountable for the outcomes the
field hasn't been held accountable for
outcomes the insurance companies have
not been held accountable for the
outcomes the country has not been held
accountable for outcomes and that has
been particularly problematic for
depression for a number of reasons
one of the one of the reasons is the
invisibility of inadequate
responses
so what can happen is that people will
start treatment maybe they start
treatment with Psychotherapy and maybe
the treatment is somewhat helpful for
them but it hasn't worked entirely and
then maybe they then add a medication to
the Psychotherapy and maybe that
medication is somewhat helpful
but not entirely but the person has gone
from an 8 out of 10 to a 5 out of ten
so they're substantially better than
they started off but they're
substantially symptomatic and in ways
that take a toll on them their social
relationships their work productivity
so why is it invisible it's invisible
because both the doctor and the patient
have worked really hard over a long
period of time to get to the point where
they're only a five
and there is justifiably
a sense of accomplishment and investment
in that new status quo
but what there is though is a failure to
say
have I exhausted all possible outcomes
to go from a five
out of 10 to a 2 out of 10. and the
answer
is
in most cases
the possible outcomes have not been
explored and this is really important we
have to keep pressing because not only
is there a possibility of adding another
kind of treatment that would be making
the patient better but there's also the
possibility that we might need to remove
a medication that's interfering with
resilience and Recovery the other thing
is that we are in a country which has
uh restricted the availability of
certain what our so-called gold standard
or definitive treatments and and one of
those would be electric convulsive
therapy now electric convulsive therapy
we know is somewhat controversial in in
areas it's obviously a treatment that
has both Medical
and in some cases cognitive risks for
patients
on the other hand what's often
appreciated and one of the reasons I
mentioned
the medical risks of depression is that
depression when untreated as medical and
cognitive risks at all that have to be
balanced against the risks of and
benefits of these treatments but the
number of sites that administer electric
convulsive therapy has been
progressively decreasing in this country
which means that access to this
treatment has become progressively
limited even though for people who fail
to respond to multiple different kinds
of medications electrical convulsive
therapy is sometimes the only treatment
that that will work
so let's if you're open to it John give
people also a preview of maybe some some
light at the end of the tunnel we're
going to talk more about
some of the biological bases
or perhaps mistaken
hypotheses about biological bases of
depression but could you give us just a
preview of
as it stands today what excites you
about some of the findings
related to ketamine as compared to other
treatment modalities and then I'm going
to come back to
and perhaps this will be part of your
answer but limitations of the serotonin
hypothesis right which has been
pervasive certainly it is
become and on on some levels a
hypothesis that even lay people will
throw around very casually
but I would love to know what excites
you about ketamine and sort of variance
thereof if you don't mind I might track
the historical story let's do it because
it's really takes us from
the serotonin hypothesis to what's
really exciting and I told you this
before and I really believe that this is
the most exciting scientific time in the
entire history of the field is
Psychiatry that we have been operating
in some ways in the dark with not a very
good understanding of what's happening
in the brain for the last 60 years and
and the sunlight is really just
beginning to penetrate into to our
understanding of the brain in ways that
are relevant to thinking about the
biology and treatment of depression and
other kinds of issues so so the
serotonin story The serotonin hypothesis
really emerged from
the appreciation of the effectiveness of
antidepressant medication treatments
you know the first the first
antidepressant that we had which was
discovered in 1957 which makes it one
year older than I am
was a drug called a monoamine oxidase
inhibitor a drug that prevented the
breakdown of norepinephrine and
serotonin two chemicals had that have
been implicated in depression and it's a
great story because the first monoamine
inhibitor given to depressed patients
was given accidentally because it was a
treatment for tuberculosis and they
discovered that the tuberculosis
patients their tuberculosis was getting
better but so was their depression and
that's how they discovered that first
antidepressant then they discovered
through a similar a little bit
accidental path the tricyclic
antidepressants then much later in the
1980s that
ssris which are like the tricyclic
antidepressants but act in a more narrow
and specific way in the brain to block
serotonin reuptake John before we move
on and I don't want to throw us off
track so we're at tricyclic and then
we're gonna move forward in the
chronology but I'm so curious
could you just briefly explain the
mechanism by which MAO inhibitors
improve
or I should say reduce symptoms of
depression what is actually happening
there
so the way that monoamine oxidase
Inhibitors work is by inhibiting an
enzyme called monoamine oxidase which is
involved in the breakdown
the metabolism of the chemicals
norepinephrine and serotonin
and so when you give a monoamine oxidase
inhibitor
you
raise the level of serotonin
norepinephrine in the synapse the space
between nerve cells and you increase the
stimulation of The receptors for those
those chemicals
and in that way they're a little bit
like the ssris which instead of
preventing the breakdown they prevent
cells from taking up out of the synaptic
space these same chemicals the monoamine
oxidase Inhibitors also release a bit
norepinephrine and serotonin so that
they release a little bit and they
prevent the uptakes they're actually
powerful antidepressant and they have
some side effects and risks that have
limited their use in modern clinical
practice but in the era in which I
trained we're very commonly prescribed
what are the main risks and side effects
and this is tying into something that's
been recently on my mind which I'll
bring up in a second then we'll hop back
into the chronology I won't lose track
but what were the side effects and what
are some of the risks of those monomial
oxidase inhibitors
as you recall these monomino mean
oxidation numbers cause a form of
release of norepinephrine serotonin and
prevent their breakdown so anything that
independent of the drug increased the
release of norepinephrine and serotonin
had the potential to produce massive
increases in norepinephrine and
serotonin in the body and so the problem
you get in if you have a massive
increase in norepinephrine is you can
get big increases in blood pressure that
can can be life-threatening
and if you get a big increase in
serotonin you can develop something
called a serotonin syndrome which can
also be very serious medically it raises
body temperature and creates a stress on
the system and the thing was that the
kinds of things that most commonly were
a problem is that there's a compound in
aged cheese
in Wines in lots of really great things
that people really enjoy eating
that has these kinds of foods have a lot
of tiramine and so people would like be
on a monoamine oxidase inhibitor and
have several glasses of Chianti with uh
cheese pizza with lots of cheese on it
aged cheese and then their blood
pressure would go through the roof and
some people would even you know have a
negative a really bad complication like
a stroke or something like that that
happened vanishingly extraordinarily
rarely and plus these medications can
interact with certain medications a
particular worrisome interaction was
they're involved with the metabolism of
meperidine or Demerol and so there there
was a famous case in New York of someone
who was on a monoamine oxidease
inhibitor who was then given Demerol in
the emergency room and then and then
died from the interaction so they're
really great drugs but you'd have to
have to be a little careful with so the
reason I'm doing some digging on this is
well there there are several reasons the
first is that there's a
there's a collection of
presentations from a symposium called
espd50 which investigated
specifically a monomial oxidase
inhibitor called harmine and the reason
they were looking at harmine is because
Harmony and Harmony and
and I believe there's at least one other
monomial oxidase that we've identified
exist in the benasteriopsis copy Vine
which is one of the two typical
ingredients in Ayahuasca and the reason
that I bring it up is that for a long
time
for Simplicity I'll just say Western
scientists largely dismissed the vine
and
ascribed to it one purpose and that was
to render the nndmt found in chakruna
they're the leaves of this shrub orally
available so that people could have
these Visionary experiences lo and
behold
a number of things are true or appear to
be true one is that the vine itself and
these monominoxidase Inhibitors which
should not be a surprise to you at all
wouldn't be have in and of themselves
therapeutic effects including increasing
brain Drive neurotrophic Factor bdnf so
that's part one part two is and I did
not realize this but you were just
discussing H cheese wine and the
tiramine content and the
contraindications that can come of that
well
some
again for Simplicity Western scientists
have also dismissed what are sometimes
referred to as dietas or Preparatory
diets related to Ayahuasca consumption
and for hundreds and thousands of years
at least so we believe given some of the
carbon dating that has been done in
places like Chile although with
different compounds but sort of outcome
related
there are restrictions there are food
restrictions that include cheese and
[Music]
fermented products I don't know the
tarmine content of fermented foods yeah
certainly alcohol prohibitions and these
have been and still are by many people
dismissed as pure Superstition well it
turns out that jungle biochemists who
have had the opportunity to run trial
and error for at least a few hundred
years may have figured out a few things
which is not to say there are tremendous
amounts of superstition
in many of these Traditions there are
but I do find the
duplication on these two lists to be
notable so that's that's why that's why
I bring it up so to come back to the the
chronology
yeah you went from the MAO inhibitors to
tricyclic
antidepressants and then we were moving
closer to present day if you wouldn't
mind continuing so my colleagues the
people that I trained with and and have
had my career with
in particular my mentor Dennis Charney
with whom we did the first ketamine
study you know they spent their careers
trying to figure out
what was the role of these chemicals
serotonin and norepinephrine in
depression and and antidepressant
treatment and
this was an era of really clever
creative psychopharmacology research
it's before
CAT scans before MRI for ephemeri before
pet scans for any of that and they had
to use pharmacology and measuring
neuroendocrine responses in Behavior as
a way to try to figure out what was
going on in the brain so just to pause
for a second so for people who may not
know the acronyms we're talking about
basically a lack of Imaging so you have
an inability to look inside the brain so
you're trying to
it's if I'm hearing you correctly you're
trying to infer what is happening Inside
by observing what is happening outside
is that a fair way to put it
so the brain is perhaps the most complex
structure in the entire universe
and you're trying to draw inferences
about what's happening in certain
connections by whether when you give a
drug does the cortisol level go up does
the prolactin level go down does it like
so it's really rough and ready
neuroscience
and it's a little bit like ptolemaic
astronomy in the sense that you have no
understanding about really how the
universe is constructed and yet
remarkably the ptolemaic astronomers
could build elaborate
explanatory systems to explain how the
planets were moving in relation to each
each other and that's really where
Psychiatry was you know in the 80s and
and this was the Leading Edge of
mechanistic research in other words the
first in some ways kinds of mechanistic
research going on in Psychiatry and
what they figured out
in building on the work of an alum
a graduate of our department who moved
to McGill Claude de Mountaineer
they developed a strategy for depleting
the body of Serotonin it builds on the
idea that tryptophan which is the
precursor for serotonin is an essential
amino acid so if you deplete the body of
free tryptophan then the body all over
the body you can't make any more
serotonin and you can drop the level of
serotonin in the blood and in the body
and in the brain so and we could use
that technique Pedro Delgado really led
the the clinical projects in those days
you could use that technique to ask
first the question
which is such a fundamental question but
had not yet been answered is serotonin
necessary for the antidepressant effects
of Prozac right couldn't be a more basic
question but we didn't know so what
Pedro did was to deplete the body of
Serotonin using this tryptophan
depletion technique which involved
giving all the other amino acids
tryptophan restricting and then giving
all the other amino acids to drive
protein synthesis and use up all the
free tryptophan so it couldn't be used
to make serotonin
dropping the serotonin levels and
producing a brief relapse of depression
and so you could show that the
antidepressant effects of drugs like
Prozac dependent on the ability of the
brain to and on an ongoing way to have a
big supply of Serotonin right
and that was really important
and it really supported mechanistic
ideas that had already been underway in
a series of pioneering Laboratories
around the country including the
laboratory of George Acadian at Yale
that at neuroadaptations
associated with serotonin synapses
really underlay the antidepressant
effects as an initial and not in some
ways ongoing mechanism of action for the
SSRI antidepressants like prosec
but
foreign
depleted serotonin
in healthy people
you did not make them depressed so there
had been an idea floating around
that depression
was a manifestation of a pure deficit in
serotonin lower serotonin you get
depressed take a Prozac you get
underpressed we knew that idea was wrong
right from the start because you take a
tablet of Prozac you do not get
underpressed from a single tablet or
Prozac it can happen it's
extraordinarily rare doesn't and it
usually doesn't last when that occurs
but the world is really complicated and
uh maybe we'll come back to it and
what's complicated is
that serotonin does have a lot of acute
effects in the brain and a single dose
of Prozac does change some things so for
example Catherine harmer at the
University of Oxford in the United
Kingdom has done a large number of
studies to show that some of the
negative biases that people have
when they're depressed go away
at least transiently with a single dose
of Prozac so it's not that there aren't
some acute effects and that those
effects aren't related to depression
it's just that this simple-minded idea
that low depression low serotonin equals
depression normal serotonin equals a
healthy life that idea is
we knew pretty much from the start
couldn't possibly
be true as it was initially suggested
the other thing I'll say just before
moving on because there's a tendency to
want to make the world simple
either it's all serotonin or it's no
serotonin but as I said would the most
complex structure in the universe really
work in such a simple-minded way that it
had to be everything or nothing probably
not
and there are brain scan studies in
depression involving positron emission
tomography the work of people like Ramin
Parsi and and others that do find some
changes in the regulation of certain
serotonin receptors that may be
intrinsic to the biology of depression
so I'm not in any way arguing for a
really simple-minded idea of depression
but I do want to highlight that these
these
monoamine depletion studies were
a
conceptual crisis like the philosopher
Thomas Kuhn would say you come to a
point where you have a body of theory
and then you have a single experiment
which in a fundamental way challenges
the idea that this idea that's
depression is simply a disorder of the
very primitive and very few number of
Serotonin cells that live in a very
primitive part of the brain the midbrain
and a little bit of the brain stem that
these
primitive cells could be the cause of
this pervasive syndrome of cognitive
behavioral and
Etc et cetera impairment
probably was
you know just that idea itself was
probably flawed from the start
but like all conceptual crises
it
was incredibly stimulating in terms of
creative thought about what the
alternatives
ideas about depression work and and so
in those days when these experiments
were going on Dennis Charney who was the
my now my boss as well as my
collaborator his office was upstairs on
the ninth floor he had a really good
view of Long Island Sound and I had a
little office on the eighth floor and
you know I would go up at the end of the
day we would talk about science and all
the things that are going on and we
wrestled with this this is one of the
things that we wrestled with a lot if it
wasn't serotonin simply
what could it be right
and
the answer was that we came to us let's
turn the brain on on its head gosh
that's a really weird turn of phrase but
let's turn this problem upside down if
depression isn't a disorder of these
really simple and few
serotonin cells in the brain then maybe
it's a disorder
that has a major part of its biology in
the parts of the brain that are
responsible for regulating emotion for
processing reward for making plans for
interpreting the world
in other words the higher cognitive
centers like the cortex cerebral cortex
and the higher emotional centers in the
limbic system
and there was a profound
consequence of that small conceptual
shift
because the cortex in the limbic system
are predominantly driven by different
chemical Messengers
than serotonin and arpinephrine
serotonin and norepinephrine tune and
and modulate the activities of the
higher brain centers but it pulled us to
think about
the intrinsic circuit mechanisms of the
cortex and limbic system and to try to
approach those circuits directly with
pharmacology
these higher brain centers predominantly
use two neurotransmitters glutamate
which accounts for something like 90
percent of the synapses of the brain
right
the main information Highway the brain
ninety percent of the synapses the main
excitatory driver for brain activity
and Gaba which is the main inhibitory
transmitter of the cortex
the function of the cerebral cortex and
limbic system is essentially a dynamic
tension like yin and yang between
factors driving excitation
and the magnitude of excitation and the
timing of excitation and the spatial
dispersion of activity in the brain
and Gaba balancing an inhibition
and we thought well
gee
how can we tap into
signaling through the main information
Highway the brain and it's really
remarkable isn't it serotonin is maybe a
couple of percentages of the synapses in
the brain
glutamate is 90
Psychiatry have been studying depression
for 50 years by that point
put all of its chips on serotonin and
norepinephrine the two percent and
completely ignoring the 98 of the other
mechanisms in the brain so we thought
well let's
try that
so
by that time I had been studying for at
least five years I'd been studying
ketamine to try to understand its role
in synaptic signaling in disorders
problems cognitive processes Behavior
other things related to schizophrenia
and we thought well we can use ketamine
to probe the Integrity of glutamate
synaptic signaling that's been what I've
been working on for the last five years
let's bring that into testing depression
and we designed a study and we gave
ketamine to depressed patients
and ketamine did transiently produce
some
you know cognitive impairment and some
changes and things like that lasted you
know an hour or so
and then those effects went away
and you know we saw
nothing special
ketamine has the same kind of effects in
depression as it does in healthy
subjects
and then the day test day we're on
and within a couple of hours people said
you know
I'm feeling a little better
we thought right
you're feeling a little better
great fantastic and then we sent them
home and then we called them the next
day did you have any bad effects from
your ketamine exposure would do you have
any hangover do you have any lasting
effects did you sleep okay the night
before and they said
you know what
my depression's all better
and we said what
uh okay
we know that these kinds of things
happen you know you give somebody a
glass of tea and the next morning a cup
of coffee
a really good croissant and the next day
they really feel better fantastic but
that you know we don't really can't rely
on the croissant effect exactly but it
happened over and over and over in this
pilot study
and it really we didn't really
know exactly what to make of it and we
started
sharing the findings with people and you
know science is just wonderful because
the dominant mode of interaction in
science is skepticism so we would
present these data and we'd say you know
people got a dose of ketamine and the
next day they were several of them were
better and they'd say right you know
skepticism overall and it took a long
time
for other groups to even try to
replicate
that ketamine finding we presented the
first results for the first time in
1997.
and the first paper of a study that
tried to replicate those ketamine
effects came out in 2006.
and that was because Dennis Charney had
moved to NIMH he had built a program he
and husseini Manji and Carla Cerati
designed and executed a study to
replicate the initial finding and you
know what they found basically exactly
what we found and then more and more
groups started to replicate that work
and find the same thing over and over
again and people started to believe it
and you know something really remarkable
happened which is that I started to give
talks and I would describe how we gave
ketamine as this research procedure and
uh It produced these antidepressant
effects and now what we need are
definitive trials because we really you
know we have preliminary evidence but we
really need to finish a trials and then
psychiatrists would tell me from the
audience what are you talking about
I've already started using ketamine in
my clinical practice and I'm having
great results
and I would like go pale
and I would freeze and I would say
well
it's still an experimental procedure you
don't have enough evidence to really
adopt it yet in clinical practice but
that's really what happened which is
somewhere in between
1997 I guess the first presentation and
the early 2000s that I started to hear
about its use
already in clinical practice which
doctors can do because it's an FDA
approved drug
and
the other key turning point
I think for the field came in 2010. with
the work of my late colleague Ron Duman
and Ron was
just an incredibly
incredible trailblazing scientist
remarkably brilliant and and talented
neuroscientist and a wonderful person
colleague and friend
and he did this study in collaboration
with George agajanian now for those in
the Psychedelic world you may be
familiar with that name but but George
agajanian and
Danny Friedman who was his mentor
around 1960 1958 1959 1960 the early
1960s did some of the first studies to
implicate serotonin signaling in the
mechanism of action of psychedelic drugs
and George was the first person the
first physiologist to record the
activity of Serotonin nerve cells in the
brain
and showing that psychedelic drugs
changed the activity rate of these
serotonin neurons giving one of the
first neural signatures of psychedelic
drugs in the brain as well so it's
really kind of
life goes full circle in a way that that
George agajanian and Ron dooman together
showed that
if you give a dose of ketamine stressed
animals
that It produced rapid and profound
biochemical
electrophysiological and structural
change in the brain within 24 hours
and and this Builds on an idea
that really came first from the
pioneering scientist Bruce McEwen
who is just another wonderful
person and scientist who is based at the
Rockefeller University
that if you stress animals
severe stress over a period of time long
period of time
that not only do they have behavioral
changes but that those behavioral
changes are associated with the loss of
the synaptic Connections in the brain
that the circuits involved in the
regulation of cognition and mood
lose a small percentage of the synapses
but enough to have profound
functional and behavioral consequences
stress related behaviors impairments in
cognition difficulty solving problems
difficulty regulating emotions
Etc all of these behavioral changes that
we associated with the emergence of
stress-related changes in animals and
depressions and people that that loss of
connections between nerve cells in the
brain are part of that series of events
and that within 24 hours of a single
dose these brain connections could go
back
what a profound new way of thinking
about what we're doing in the brain
and one of the things that's maybe a
subtle point but to me profound is
I view depression treatment is about
thinking about how we restore behavioral
and emotional resilience and how we can
tap into the brain's intrinsic capacity
for resilience to promote behavioral
resilience so what we've done
by giving a single dose Academy an
innate and is we're not making random
new Connections in the brain that would
be a bad thing the brain is not chaotic
structure and we don't want to make
random connections because that would
make things worse in theory I mean
that's what you get with epilepsy a
growth of inappropriate Connections in
in parts of the brain
what we do is overcome whatever
intrinsic resistance there is to
Recovery in the brain
to
give a brief pulse of Academy and enable
a restoration of the brain's intrinsic
capacity to develop and maintain
structural connectivity
and we think that is a part of the story
of how ketamine works in the brain and
that that Insight happened around 2010
and that was really fundamentally
important in terms of driving the whole
field forward and helping to reduce a
lot of the skepticism about ketamine as
a treatment
so looking at the Timeline I just want
to recap a little bit and I have several
questions because I love
The History of Science and I feel like
one of the best ways to try to hone
oneself not speaking for myself because
I'm just a tourist but
to prepare the mind for future
discoveries to examine past discoveries
so let me just lay out a few things for
folks number one is
timelines so animal studies in the early
1990s suggest there might be
antidepressant effects I'm going to come
back to that 1997 your first
presentation of results
2000 first paper is published 2006
publication of the first replication big
deal
that was in treatment resistant
depression and then we may come back to
this but 2019 FDA approval of s-ketamine
so my question
to begin is related to Ron Duman and the
animal research with ketamine so for
people who really have no history on
ketamine and I want you to fact check
this and and correct me if I get
anything wrong but ketamine is a
dissociative anesthetic it is widely
used very inexpensive it is partially so
widely used because it does not at least
normally suppress respiration so you
find it being used in military
capacities in the field and veterinary
medicine but it's not a horse
tranquilizer per se which is I think
what some people believe but it is used
in medicine and it is one of the World
Health organization's most essential
medicines and this is a pervasive
and aesthetic
how did
Ron or others involved with the animal
research even choose that
as an intervention to begin with
so first I have to tell you about a
cartoon that I saw about ketamine
related to its use as a horse
tranquilizer which is the cartoon says I
think related to the abuse Academy and
it says ketamine and it's got a picture
of a horse just say nay n-e-i-g-h
that's good
at the time that I was studying ketamine
I was interacting you know regularly
with this broader group of people at Ron
Duma was at Yale Georgia Yale Eric
nestler Dennis Charney obviously my
collaborator mentor and many other
people so one of the things that was
really striking was when I was when we
had made this finding
with ketamine and shared the results
with Ron
I had the feeling that Ron thought that
it was more important than we did he
would say this is like the most
important finding in 50 years and we
would say what
and so he was really highly motivated to
try to understand how ketamine worked
and his own research
was in the area of the basic
Neuroscience of stress and
antidepressant activity he showed for
example he was the first to show that
antidepressants stimulates something
called neurogenesis which is the birth
of new nerve cells in the hippocampus in
animals and and there's been some work
to show that that might happen in human
brain as well and
he was one of the pioneers of studying
the role of of neurotrophic signaling
in depression and its treatment so his
laboratory had all the pieces of the
story about how nerve
growth might be involved in
antidepressant treatment and and so he
he was in some ways
uniquely
situated to discover this profound
structural change and they didn't what
was really important about the work is
they not not only that they describe the
profound structural change but they
mapped the molecular signaling
mechanisms
that you alluded to about nerve growth
factors engaging
a fundamental mechanism for resilience
in the brain these growth factors
as a consequence of chemical
communication in the brain so although
ketamine is a glutamate receptor blocker
one of the things that it does is block
the excitation of inhibition inhibitory
cells that's a really complicated it's
like
if you had a break
and then you had another break that you
stepped on to relieve the break instead
of stepping on the gas pedal that's what
ketamine is like in the brain so so
ketamine allows more glutamate release
to happen in certain circuits of the
brain
and it you get a pulse if you will of
glutamate which is good for the brain as
opposed to sustained high levels of
glutamate which is toxic for the brain
the brain is really sensitive to
temporal Dynamics so a pulse of
glutamate is good that stimulates a type
of glutamate receptor that triggers the
elevation of bdnf levels it causes a
local seepage of bdnf the nerve growth
factor out of the nerve cells
and activates signaling and then a key
way station and I'm going to get a
little technical because we I know we're
probably going to come back to this
point later yeah a keyway station in the
signaling of the nerve growth factor is
a protein in nerve cells that's got the
name mtor or mtorq and mtor is an
abbreviation for something really
complicated the mechanistic target of
rapamycin
and it turns out that if you activate
mtor
then you activate all the downstream
mechanisms that lead to the regrowth and
stabilization of these new synaptic
connections
now
this might be a good time
to come back and think about a little
bit about the complexity of the
neurobiology of glutamate abnormalities
in depression I think we should do that
but I want to
just follow up on what you said to ask
yeah how did how was the hypothesis
formed at all that
ketamine
instead of a million other interventions
or you know pharmacological tools
might be useful for
preparing the
structural damage of stress or
alleviating Depression was it something
that was observed in the field for
instance one of the rumors that I've
heard is that veterans who are
administered this anesthetic seemed to
experience less PTSD that was somehow
recorded in the field and that led to
hypothesis generation and and use of
ketamine that seems pretty tenuous I
don't know if that's true but how did it
go from
anesthetic to
of all the things we could choose we're
gonna mess around with ketamine
first off I love hearing stories about
how I I and Dennis came up with ketamine
for depression but it's one of my I like
like people uh you know it's like oh
that's a great idea no
to be clear this isn't specific to you
it's just I I I'm so fascinated by the
the Genesis stories of these things I
think they're important so I'd love to
hear the the real story as opposed to
the Santa Claus version so the real
story
is not related to depression at all it's
related to to schizophrenia so it so
happens in the great Cosmic
Universe of coincidence
that
a friend of my dad's in Detroit
friend of our and his family was a
friend of our family and we went on
vacation together
I remember
inner tubing down a river in northern
Michigan I grew up in Michigan inner
tubing down a river
with his daughter we were maybe 10 or 9
or 10 at the time his daughter is now
is named Joan Luby
um she's now an endowed Professor an
expert in child psychiatry at Washington
University in St Louis
anyway this fellow's name was
um
Elliott Luby
and in 1959
he published a paper
that was the first time fin cycladine or
cernal was given to a human being
this happened at the Lafayette clinic in
Detroit an entity a building which no
longer exists unfortunately in extremely
extremely
generative place in its era
and he said that if you gave cernal
which which was the company name for
pencilidine PCP angel dust if you gave
it to people It produced something like
schizophrenia in them
the thing was that's 1959.
and the mechanism the fact that it
blocked the nmda glutamate receptor
wasn't identified until the mid-1980s or
in 83 84.
so
it was this
fascinating observation which couldn't
go anywhere scientifically but they did
research and this is going to bring us
to other topics that we'll probably talk
about
in which they compared the effects of
pencilidine to the effects of LSD in
people yeah good old psychomimetic yeah
it's just just unbelievably courageous
and creative trailblazing
psychopharmacology at a time when they
just had no idea what was happening in
the brain the neurobiology
and in the early 60s
another
trailblazing scientists also associated
with that group was a guy named ed
Domino
who was a pharmacologist it's a great
name too yeah my cousin Tom I apologize
for mentioning his name who is a medical
student at the University of Michigan
brought me to sit in one of his classes
when I was
applying to medical schools and it just
happened to be Ed Domino and my friends
my cousin and his friends when Ed Domino
came up to talk saying a bit of the Van
Morrison
song Domino
[Laughter]
may be familiar with anyway
Unforgettable to me because Ed became a
very dear friend and colleague over the
years but Ed
was the first to give
ketamine to animals and humans and
because it was a shorter acting safer
version of a small structural
modification
in the van cycladine chemical structure
that made it possible to
be shorter acting more manageable easier
to control and for what reason was he
administering the ketamine in in those
particular studies for anesthesia for
anesthesia got it yeah there was a
fellow Corson who was working with him
on some of those studies
so there's a line that I love you know
one of these I love
portentous lines in scientific
literature
like I think it's the last line in the
Watson and Crick discovery of DNA where
they say
it has not escaped our notice that the
elucidation of the structure of DNA may
have relevance for
the transmission of genetic traits or
something like that something
unbelievably understated
and there's a line in one of the first
papers on ketamine that
Ed Domino wrote which was when you give
ketamine to
humans we notice that sensory
information can get to sensory cortex
unimpeded but is altered or or blocked
in its transmission to Association
cortex we call this
dissociation
and this process dissociative anesthesia
something like that and wow what a
profound cast off sentence right and
buried in the discussion of a paper in
an anesthesia Journal but really what
happened was that this group of pioneers
had an incredible tool but no conceptual
framework to use it to generate
in a real deep scientific insight
and and that's because they were
30 years ahead of the field or something
like that and
you know it wasn't even known that there
was a binding site for fence cycling
so first studies published in 1959
wasn't even known that there was a
binding site for fence cycloidine until
1979 Now by Bindings that you mean a
receptor that it could a plate well some
kind of something some kind of something
they didn't know that it acted in a
specific way at a specific Target in
their brain what that Target was they
didn't yet know until the early 1980s
that it was a glutamate receptor yeah
it's wild they didn't even know that
there was a binding site for fence
cycling until a really
Landmark paper in 1979 from
Steve and Suzanne zukin so it was
Darkness right it was like the Middle
Ages
of Neuroscience
and so they they had a brilliant Insight
but they couldn't take it anywhere
because there was no framework for it so
join the faculty in Ada at Yale and I
wasn't sure what I was going to do
and my boss said to me that Dr Chinese
said well you can be the
chief of the schizophrenia program or
the deputy chief of the PTSD program
and I I said well
I like the idea of being the chief
that's how I went into the field of
schizophrenia research
and so I found myself
as a new
completely
you know inexperienced
schizophrenia researcher setting up a
research program related to the
neurobiology and treatment of
schizophrenia
and it happened
to be just at that time that clozapine
which is an antipsychotic medication
that's a little bit more effective than
other antipsychotics I was introduced
and I've been raised studying monoamine
pharmacology that's what I knew that's
really
what I had anticipated studying and I
tried I treated patients with clozapine
and I thought it was pretty good
medication
but I didn't want my legacy after 40
Years of schizophrenia research to be
that he figured out why clozapine was a
little bit more effective than other
antipsychotic medications so I felt like
I just had to
go out of the box
and you know this is um this is where my
father's Legacy really
had a big impact it's like
well if you could do anything
what would you do
and and it was like well I don't want to
study
these few cells
contributing to the
you know dopamine or norepinephrine I
want to study the main information
Highway of the brain just a few years
before they figured out that drugs like
ketamine PCP blocked this receptor for
glutamine
and so what brought me to ketamine
was really the effort to probe glutamate
synaptic function in higher cortical
circuits
as a way of understanding the cognitive
impairments negative symptoms and other
aspects of schizophrenia and so our path
in our Institution
my path
was
the development of a research program on
glutamate
psychopharmacology
developing circuit and mechanistic
hypotheses one of my collaborators in
those days was a pharmacologist named
beta mogada
and in 19
97
she published a paper
that showed that ketamine released
glutamate in the brain at the very same
doses that we were using the equivalent
of the very same doses that we were
using to produce changes in cognition
and psychosis related to schizophrenia
you know that line of research has its
own story because we began using the
ketamine Administration as a platform
for trying to identify novel
alternatives to antipsychotic medication
for the treatment of schizophrenia and
and that has had its own life and story
and maybe someday we'll we'll talk about
that but
one of the things beta found which
turned out to be profoundly important
for the antidepressant story
was if you give it at the sub anesthetic
dose that we use
to study cognition it released glutamate
if you give it at anesthetic doses it
depresses glutamine and it's not
antidepressant at those Doses and if you
give it at even a little bit lower level
it doesn't stimulate the glutamate
release there's a tiny narrow window
where it's producing dissociation
psychosis and a number of the other
effects that we're really interested in
where it works
and turns out that that little narrow
dose window
is the dose range where it works for the
treatment of depression we just stumbled
on that
because it was optimal
you know the thing was we couldn't give
higher doses to people because we needed
them to
perform cognitive tests and be able to
answer our questions when we gave people
much higher doses of ketamine
they would have
you know pretty interesting experiences
but they couldn't answer any of our
questions so it wasn't any good for me
as a research tool I mean I remember one
person that we gave this higher dose of
ketamine to who
couldn't answer a lot of our questions
but he was holding on to the bed really
tightly
and I said well that's interesting why
were you holding onto the bed he said
well
basically the
the dress the blue and the dress of the
interviewer had become outer space the
white polka dots in her dress had become
planets and solar systems and his bed
was flying among the planets and the the
other planets and he was afraid that if
he let go of the bed that he'd be cast
adrift in outer space and and not make
it back well that was really fascinating
it seems reasonable
yeah it was really really interesting
but useless I couldn't get him he
couldn't do any tests he couldn't
perform anything so what that
essentially did was create
the upper bound of the dosing that we
were using with ketamine and then the
lower doses
just turned out to be completely
ineffective and have repeatedly been
shown to be so in in single doses in
antidepressant trials so that's how we
got to ketamine
and that's how we got to the dose of
ketamine and the route of ketamine that
we used in the treatment studies because
what we did was to adapt
the dose and the duration of
administration
like you could have said why 40 minutes
well because ketamine is such a
short-acting drug
we administer it for 40 minutes to give
us a Time window where people are having
the subjective effects of ketamine where
we can test behavioral and cognition
that's why we had the slow infusion in
the initial study
and we just imported that into
depression and that has become the
standard treatment
infusion Paradigm for racemic ketamine
Administration for the treatment of
depression so John may I interject for a
second sure so I want to talk about
I think we'll get to this pretty quickly
basically what you consider best
practices in terms of format dosing
schedule
etc
for ketamine as applied to depression
and if you want to take the conversation
somewhere else first that's totally fine
but I would love to have you just
translate an earlier definition which
was
in more let's just call it science speak
for the lay person and that is a
definition of dissociation
and then
whether that is a feature or a bug
whether that is important for the
clinical outcomes or it is a side effect
to be removed and this is highly
relevant to the broader conversation
including psychedelics because there are
many efforts and different camps some
who believe the say psychedelic effects
are critical to clinical outcomes and
then those who view them as side effects
to be removed could you Define
dissociation and then share your
perspective on whether it is helpful
AKA desirable or undesirable
in the in the effects that we see the
antidepressant effects
you know sometimes I have started papers
on dissociation and stopped because I
would get hung up on what the definition
of dissociation is
our consciousness
our experience of the world
our sense of ourself in the world
our sense of our bodies
our sense of ourselves embedded in time
all of these things which
people take for granted
are constructions of our brain active
constructions and when these fundamental
aspects of the organization of
consciousness
are perturbed
we experience ourselves
as disconnected
from ourselves
in other words depersonalized
or in an artificial state
which is also called derealization in
other words that you're in an altered
reality
and those
states of derealization and
depersonalization as well as distortions
in our
perception of ourselves
and the perception of the world as
integrated
are collectively what we tend to refer
to as dissociative States because
dissociation meaning disconnected from
what's going on around us but really
it's a much more profound and nuanced
idea because you can have some
Distortion of dissociation in some
dimensions and not others and it can be
very nuanced I got interested in
dissociation
because of working with Vietnam veterans
with post-traumatic stress disorder and
for whom dissociation is a
complication or a part of the syndrome
of post-traumatic stress disorder for
many people
and it's a whole nuanced range of things
from these states of feeling
disconnected and and that things are not
real
too sensory distortions
to
what people know as a very
dramatic aspect of PTSD which are these
flashbacks where people are completely
absorbed in another state and lose touch
with what's happening around them and so
one of the things that was exciting
about the initial ketamine research
was that it was not only providing us a
way a new way to think about the
neurobiology of psychosis and cognitive
impairments associated with
schizophrenia but it was also at the
same time providing us with really the
first
pure
kind of neurobiological path to studying
the neurobiology of dissociation in PTSD
and that's a whole other kind of
discussion which we can we can come back
to so
what about dissociation in the
antidepressant if executive this is
really an interesting and complicated
question because to really answer your
question you have to acknowledge I have
to acknowledge that I'm a translational
neuroscientist and psychiatrist
I do work on trying to understand the
most basic aspects of
biochemistry synaptic signaling Network
function computational modeling whatever
and so
there are aspects of engaging in
treatment that are not
so close to that like what did it mean
to me to go through this experience and
and so a lot of people say that the
dissociative experience is a very
meaningful experience for them uh
particularly if there's some kind of
guided experience to do that and I have
no argument with that whatsoever
why not
in fact that's great
but
I've seen a lot of people who get
ketamine for treatment
and a lot of people who just get
ketamine I've given well over a thousand
doses of ketamine to people
from it's not really that much of a
meaningful experience I've had people
say things like
well
my parents scrimped and saved to send me
to medical school and now I'm losing
control of my thought processes during
ketamine I'm throwing away my parents
investment you know that you know these
kinds of scary thoughts my
my organs are being replaced with
machine parts
that sounds unpleasant yeah you know
stuff like that and that is not a
productive insight and it's not feeling
it's not important for them to even
remember that after the ketamine is worn
off
so I would say the dissociation is
clearly not a necessity
in terms of producing attitude change
and things like that
I would also say that some people they
get the ketamine and
and once had a treated a guy or it
wasn't she was a research study but I
gave him a dose Academy he had come from
a Mormon background he had never had
coffee and never had tea never had
alcohol never smoked never used any drug
and and he described ketamine as the
most fun he ever had since he arrived at
Yale so it was like a roller coaster of
like doing all these things I mean it
clearly has that heart to it as well
so the question is is dissociation
telling us something important and I
think there are ways that it does
on my side of the street which is that
as I've mentioned
it just so happens
that the dose of ketamine that is
optimal
for inducing the antidepressant effects
is for many people the dose at which
they experience dissociative symptoms
the dose that produces the therapeutic
effects the Dosa produce dissociation
overlap so that if you're giving a dose
of ketamine that is is not producing any
dissociative symptoms for some people it
will mean you have underdosed the
ketamine when there are exceptions to
this in that some people are just not
very sensitive to the dissociative
effects of ketamine but still get the
antidepressant effects and examples of
those people are people who have a
personal or family history of alcohol
use disorder who seem to have a built-in
tolerance to the effects Academy as they
do have a built-in tolerance some of
them to the effects of
alcohol and that's another story we can
get to if you want sometime but what my
colleagues
Irina Estrellas and Sophie Holmes and
and the broader
group of collaborators with Yale pet
center did a study which I think is
incredibly important and interesting
related to the neurobiology academy
which sheds light a little bit on
dissociation and that is
they had previously reported that a
subgroup of patients with relatively
more severe depression had reductions in
synaptic density and they could show
that with pet scans with using a
molecular tag for synapses
and so okay so there's these depressed
patients who have reductions in synaptic
density
great so that so far that could be
relevant to translating the animal work
to the human work
so you give a mixed group of depression
patients some who have synaptic deficits
others who don't have synaptic deficits
and you give them a dose of ketamine
what happens this paper was from this
same group published this year turns out
that the people who have synaptic
deficits which are the more treatment
resistant the more severely ill more
chronically ill
et cetera et cetera the more hardcore
depressed patients
they get a dose Academy
they get an increase in synaptic density
and the more dissociative symptoms they
get
the bigger the increase in synaptic
density and the bigger the increase in
synaptic density
the greater their clinical Improvement
pilot data really preliminary but very
interesting so it suggests that in
people who have synaptic deficits
that dissociative symptoms produced by
ketamine can be a marker
that you've got enough ketamine into the
brain and you're triggering the
therapeutic antidepressant effects but
what about those
other depressed patients the other half
of the patients with depression who are
getting ketamine
they don't have synaptic deficits
what happens to them they get
dissociation too
but
dissociation in those patients is
unrelated to their clinical response and
if anything it's not really so
meaningful but there's a little bit of a
trend that the more dissociation they
get the less Improvement they get not
meaningful but maybe it's there a little
bit so
so dissociation in these two groups of
patients during ketamine means two
different things yeah in one it's a
signature of clinical Improvement and
another it's not and what that
highlights is really number one ketamine
is doing different things because the
people who don't have synaptic deficits
are still getting clinical Improvement
overall
but they're not getting clinical
Improvement that's related to the
restoration of structural connectivity
they don't have that kind of depression
they don't have the deficits in synaptic
density and it's not regrowing so what
could it be right so I'm gonna take a
step back to point out that
reduction in the density of synaptic
Connections in the brain isn't the only
kind of glutamate abnormality that we
have in depression another kind of
abnormality that we've seen in in people
with PTSD and depression
and that was published
this year also
from the first author is a colleague
Teddy Abdullah who's now at uh Baylor
College of Medicine
using a really newfangled clever
technical technique where we can give a
isotopically tagged
infusion of acetate or glucose
and then track its incorporation into a
variety of metabolic intermediates in
the brain
this technique allows us
to measure two things one is
how much glutamate's being released
and how much metabolic activity is
triggered
okay
so you can say glutamate amount of
metabolic activity per glutamate
it's a measure of the effectiveness of
that synaptic connection how much is
glutamate able to activate the brain
lo and behold in some circuits in the
frontal cortex
there's a reduction in the effectiveness
of synaptic efficiency in depression in
the frontal cortex pretty crude measure
so not necessarily certain trip not
necessarily A deficit in synaptic
density but just a decreased efficiency
exactly yeah another deficit
and so one of the ideas related to that
is that probably that reduction in
efficiency efficacy is present more
broadly in depression
and only a subgroup of the more severe
chronic more treatment resistant
depression
have the
reduction in synaptic density
so maybe the reason that
you get some people getting better with
depression
when they get ketamine
is for some people it's unrelated to the
restoration of the synapses and it has
to do with an increase in the efficiency
or effectiveness of these synaptic
connections
what is the evidence to support that
hypothesis a wonderful study conducted
by Allison Nugent and Carlos arati they
used another cool technique called
Magneto encephalography sort of like if
you will EEG but with a magnetic signal
rather than an electrical signal gets a
little deeper into the brain a little
higher sensitivity and what they showed
is that you give a dose of ketamine and
well first that that sensory evoked
potentials the ability of a sensory
input to activate the brain and you can
measure that electrical or magnetic
signature if you will using this
technique
that's a little bit blunted in depressed
patients
and if you give a single dose of
ketamine to to patients with depression
you'll discover that there are two
groups those who
don't respond those people who don't
respond don't show any change in the
magnitude of this evoked response in the
brain but the people who do respond show
an increase in the evoked response in
other words the synaptic connections get
potentiated functionally and not
structurally
and so what we
take from these kinds of studies and
others like functional fmri studies and
other things from ketamine is that
ketamine has the ability both to
increase the functionality of synapses
something that probably happens very
rapidly within hours of ketamine
Administration and for some people will
be the bulk of their antidepressant
response and and restore synaptic
connections
and that happens in a more delayed way
and is involved in sustaining for many
people the antidepressant response and
we know a lot about the mechanisms
because it directly emerges out of Von
duman's work and and beta mogadon's work
you know a lot about
the biology of the structural
restoration of structural connectivity
and we know much less at this point
about how ketamine restores the
efficiency of the network but my sense
is that both are probably contributing
to the clinical effect so let me hop in
for a second because I'm enjoying this
so much and learning so much and a few
things come to mind for me the first is
that
we're talking about the
sort of neuroanatomical changes or maybe
not neuroanatomical but the certain
activity changes in some cases
structural changes that you observe and
the clinical outcomes that you see in
different breeds of depressed patients
right those with lower synaptic density
I wouldn't use that word but uh I say
breast types subtypes there we go right
I feel like you know
I'm kind of allowed to play it fast and
loose since I fit into the broad
category of someone who who has
treatment resistant depression so I feel
like I can kind of Sling Loosely but
right but you have different responses
to different
different types of depression and part
of me wonders
if their subjective experiences are also
different and just by way of analogy
I'll say I think that labels can be so
reductionist that it's easy to run into
confounding factors or to run into
confusion and this is true in many many
areas not just Psychiatry and I think
about for instance Cardiology and
dealing with
lipid markers that are out of whack and
how
how brute force and
non-specific certain approaches are high
cholesterol statins right instead of
automatically doing that which can be a
tool in the toolkit determining if one
is a hyper absorber of cholesterol
versus a hyper producer of cholesterol
versus fill in the blank in which case
your first line approach might be say
something like acetamine rosettia
instead of a Statin which could then be
looked at later if the sort of clinical
changes aren't achieved
and similarly I can imagine that in a
group of depressed self-described
depressed patients even if they take an
assessment uh like uh not sure what the
proper assessment would be like a ham D
or something like that
that the subjective experience as you
noted earlier in this conversation for
one of these subgroups could be
anhedonia right so they have an
inability to feel Joy
but they're not
stuck in a endless loop of perseverating
negativity
and again I'm speculating here yeah yeah
but to then jump from that I can imagine
that for some people
perhaps those who also respond to the
dissociative effects or let me be clear
I have a high correlation of positive
improvements to achieving those
dissociative effects with dosing that
maybe they're the ones who have this
self-hatred on endless loop and the
dissociative effects have
impart some of the subtraction of that
so they feel what it is like to exist
without that Loop playing endlessly and
this is one of my and I am such a
tourist so I I want to dive into this
further with you but
having gone through a five in few well I
was supposed to be six I ended up doing
five infusion sequence myself
I was struck by how you can experience
what it is like to not have a loop or a
repetitive thought pattern and that
sometimes that subjective experience
putting aside that there are certainly
other things happening in the brain
can feel tremendously therapeutic even
in the moment
versus say perhaps those who had
positive outcomes but didn't seem to
need the dissociative effect I'm
simplifying here perhaps just didn't
have that Loop issue it was it presented
differently for them these are just
thoughts that are occurring to me as
we're talking and we're going to dig
into all sorts of this let me ask if I
may
foreign just because I think people are
are chomping at the bit for this and
then we're going to go in a bunch of
different directions
if you had say close friend ended up
working with you or a doctor you trust
in a clinical capacity
with treatment resistant depression
what would the formatting dosing Etc
look like might it look like for that
person recognizing that maybe it's you
know migs per kigs or weight dependent
or whatever but what might it look like
because before we start recording and
also based on what you said perhaps
10-15 minutes ago there's a response
curve where too little doesn't do the
trick too much also doesn't seem to do
the trick there's this Goldilocks yeah
narrow dosing window but also there are
all these other questions intravenous
versus intramuscular versus something
else is is there therapy during the
session or only before and after right
so could you speak to sort of what that
friend with someone who's highly
competent with perhaps your input
what that experience of ketamine might
look like
the first thing is the choice of s
ketamine versus intravenous ketamine and
it's really
it's really not clear
how they stack up against each other in
terms of efficacy and tolerability
there's a clear difference in
ease of use
which is
if you're the sort of person who doesn't
like needles
then getting the medication intranasal
is a huge
benefit
in and if you're the sort of person who
doesn't like sticking things in your
nose
then getting ketamine intravenously
would be a benefit
and that sounds like a trivial thing
but there are a lot of people who don't
get a lot of treatment because they're
afraid of needles and that can be a
problem for some people and S ketamine
can be given intranasially and that's
really can be given in more settings it
makes it easier to give it in different
kinds of settings that might mean more
congenial and all has all kinds of other
implications and for the sake of our
hypothetical let's say this person is
not averse to Needles so IV or
intramuscular is okay so then there are
some differences that favor the
intravenous one is that
the intravenous dose is dosed on a
milligram per kilogram basis
whereas there's a fixed milligram dose
for the
s ketamine and because of the fixed
milligram dose of s ketamine
it's recommended that you start at 56
milligrams of ascetamine
and then work your way up if you
tolerate that to 84 milligrams
and that means that for many people
they're going to start on a dose which
is not the maximally therapeutic dose
for them or maybe even an ineffective
dose for them before they get to a
therapeutic dose and that means that
they for some people that they have to
wait till they get to the higher dose to
get
much in the way of clinical benefit so
that is a subtle point but if someone is
getting to
ketamine as a treatment because they
want the rapid response that there's a
little bit of an advantage for getting
the full dose of ketamine
intravenously it's a theoretical
Advantage whether it's a real clinical
Advantage still or early to say because
we don't we'd only have good
head-to-head data it's mostly derived
from comparison of secondary data
secondary analyzes
but for some people there may be an
advantage of the intravenous dose I'd
love for you to also just speak to the
cost differences uh potentially yeah so
the S ketamine is a little bit expensive
medications about 600 treatment maybe
you know depending on where you're
getting your achievement can be it can
be more
but it's usually covered by insurance or
at least in many places covered by
insurance so it's more of a cost for the
overall health system than it is often
for the individual but sometimes it's
the individuals paying out of pocket and
ketamine is obviously generic and much
less expensive
so let's say they are
suffering from acute depression maybe
suicidal ideation I mean putting aside
the other
precautions it might be taking in such a
situation but let's just say it's acute
depression they're looking for Rapid
antidepressant effects
what then what does the how many
sessions over what period of time what
is a session itself look like I would
just love to to know what's the the
current
state of the art without some of the
forward-looking stuff we'll get to what
the future might look like but just as
it stands right now if someone wanted to
go to a clinic today well I think that
this is an evolving story
and when we're talking about ketamine
for treatment resistant depression it
tends to be administered in many clinics
without any attendant Psychotherapy so
for example people will come in they'll
get the ketamine they'll hang around for
another hour or two and and then head
out and they'll do that
for the initial four weeks
at least four weeks they'll do it twice
a week
most people after four weeks of twice a
week will go to once a week
and if they tolerate that eventually
they'll go to once every other week
and after a longer term treatment
several months some people will go to
every three weeks sometimes as
infrequently as once a month and be able
to be maintained on ketamine after that
a lot of people will do
short-term course six treatments ten
treatments 12 treatments and they'll do
that course to get back to a remission
of their depression and some people are
able to then just stay on their on their
ongoing treatment usually people are in
some kind of ongoing treatment before
they come to ketamine we don't stop
their standard medications basically if
they're taking a sedative medication
during the day or anxiolytic medication
like a benzodiazepine will ask them to
hold it on the mornings that they get
their Academy so that there's not an
interaction there so some people will
just do a course and then they'll be
done but others will need ongoing some
kind of ongoing maintenance treatment to
sustain the benefit
now with someone who again a friend of
yours that you refer to a clinician you
trust
would you in such a case tend to lean
towards the four weeks of two times a
week then one time a week or would you
tend to lean towards and again we said
this in the introduction I will have
recorded this by the time this comes out
this is not medical advice this is for
educational purposes only so obviously
speak to your own general practitioner
or physician before considering anything
like this but would you tend to lean
towards four weeks two times a week and
then the the sort of tape ring so to
speak not tapering but the greater
distribution after that or the more
perhaps aggressive
higher frequency per week
and then what does an individual session
what might an individual session look
like in terms of duration milligrams per
kilogram
psychotherapeutic wrapper if one
so there's very limited data comparing
modes of ketamine Administration there
was a small study that suggested that
three times a week or modest study that
suggested that three times a week is no
better than two times a week in terms of
the effectiveness or the duration of the
antidepressant effects so the twice a
week startup
tends to be the standard frequency there
are some people who think that Mast
ketamine treatments in other words three
consecutive days or multiple days in a
row might produce more lasting benefit I
don't think we can conclude that yet
from the evidence that we have so we
tend to do twice a week
so in my view
for treatment resistant depression this
is a pretty good strategy the question
about how to wrap Psychotherapy around
this is really an interesting one and
and there are some important points to
make
about ketamine generally
before going into the wraparound
treatment because
in my view ketamine is an intervention
and it's part of an overall treatment
in other words it's really important
that somebody is thinking about the
overall well-being of the patient
providing support providing oftentimes
psychotherapy
and thinking about how the other
medications that patients are taking are
interacting with the ketamine and
looking out in a big picture way for the
overall well-being of patients Academy
is an intervention embedded in overall
treatment and for many people
there's some kind of ongoing
Psychotherapy and there's evidence that
because ketamine increases the
neuroplasticity of the brain that there
may be Synergy between ketamine and
other treatments that are given outside
of the ketamine session in other words
oftentimes sessions 24 hours after and
and that these sessions can both
potentially extend and and augment the
effectiveness of ketamine such uh paper
by Sam Wilkinson here at Yale suggests
that but there's also this interesting
question about what do you do during the
ketamine infusion
and I think that this question is
particularly relevant when you're
in a way treating the impact of
maladaptive memories what do I mean by
maladaptive memories I mean things like
early life trauma
current traumatic experiences
addiction
which is a kind of reward learning if
you will
and what we have found in a study led by
Elon harpaz Roto is that
if you activate trauma memories during
the ketamine infusion
then the potency of those trauma
memories is greatly reduced you know
people with PTSD have a lot of concern
that treatment would in some way Rob
them of their trauma memories and impede
their overall ability to be advocates
for the groups that they're often
committed to in other words say combat
veterans to their fellow combat veterans
or
rape survivors to other rape survivors
and and oftentimes they believe that
that the trauma memories are
a burden but
in some ways valuable to them and and I
would want to reassure anybody who is in
that kind of state that we're not
talking about removing or deleting
memories in any way that all we're
trying to do is to reduce the intensity
of these memories so that they don't
interfere with with the ability to
achieve things in life and and they
don't fear with quality of life so if
you activate a trauma memory or an
alcohol or say for alcohol use disorder
memory during ketamine you tend to
reduce the potency of that memory
for a long period of time surprising
period of time
after the event what we don't yet know
is how it fits in the overall treatment
of these folks in the sense that there
are some signs that you can reduce the
potency of a particular trauma memory so
that you can talk about the worst event
that ever happened and now it doesn't
trigger a whole exacerbation of their
PTSD symptoms but it doesn't necessarily
resolve the broader issues and this is
partly a bit about what I'm talking
about about the broader
psychotherapeutic context for for
ketamine which is that there's an
overall treatment process and then
there's the
intervention and what we can reasonably
expect from it but there is a sign that
not only craving for alcohol but
actually alcohol consumption may be
reduced from an initial preliminary
study conducted by a group
in London Ravi Das is the the lead
author on that paper it was in nature
Communications a few years ago and
people are trying to develop that into a
treatment for alcohol use disorder quick
question on that is that independent of
the content of the session in other
words is that a
pharmacological factors that in
combination with say bringing up maybe
early trauma that they attribute their
alcohol use disorder alcoholism
too so this is one of the kind of really
interesting byproducts of
ketamine in relation to other drugs like
the psychedelics so ketamine because it
blocks the nmda glutamate receptor
block certain forms of neuroplasticity
in the brain and we think that every
time you activate a memory you put it
that memory into a somewhat labile state
in other words you can strengthen the
impact of that memory by rehearsing it
in a negative way and in fact we think
that's part of how PTSD develops you
have a negative trauma memory you bring
it up you rehearse it it gets more
powerful it has a bigger impact on your
life you do that over and over again in
the whole narrative
starts to be integrated in your life
like a bad habit and your your reaction
and expectation of trauma becomes
triggered every time that memory gets
activated
same thing is like an addiction use the
alcohol you like it use it again you
like it a little bit more and you are
using it over and over and over and
those alcohol related memories have more
and more power in the way you think in
the way you act and so by interfering
with neuroplasticity and preventing that
strengthening process you actually
weaken the impact of those memories and
we think that that can be helpful that's
maybe relevant to some addictions it may
be relevant to PTSD and particularly
relevant to PTSD because in a large
for its kind of large study that we
published this year with about 50
patients in the group where we compared
standard dose ketamine to a lower dose
ketamine to Placebo in people with
military related PTSD
we found that there was a robust
antidepressant effect but a really weak
and didn't quite meet statistical
significance effect on the core PTSD
symptoms so it may be that if you want
just the antidepressant effect you can
just give a dose Academy to people with
PTSD but if you want the full-blown
maximal impact on PTSD you may have to
activate the trauma memories in the
context of the ketamine infusion to get
the full benefit and that seems to be
different than major depression where a
lot of people are a reasonably large
number of people with not PTSD but major
depression will have a major clinical
response just to the pharmacologic
effect of the drug even if no
reactivating of memories happens during
the infusion
John we've been talking about best
practices let's get into some of the
nitty-gritty of dosing because it seems
like too little doesn't do the job too
much also counterproductive on some
levels
what are the milligrams per kilogram
best practices to achieve that
let's call it optimal or at least land
in the narrow therapeutic window
we have the most information
for a 40-minute intravenous infusion and
so the 40-minute intravenous infusion
dose that we most commonly use is 0.5
milligrams per kilogram and there I'm
told that there are some people who
are very unresponsive to the 0.5
milligram per kilogram dose and I've
heard that there are some cases where
you would go to 0.6 or 0.7 and can
sometimes
get a good effect
but people generally don't go much
higher than that and similarly generally
speaking if you go much lower than 0.5
milligram for example down to 0.2
milligrams it's hardly effective for
anyone it there are some people who are
extremely sensitive to 0.5 where you can
dial it down a little bit maybe 0.4
milligrams per kilogram and have less
side effects and and still get some
efficacy so it's a really narrow range I
mean if you think about almost any
medication that you take take aspirin
people take two aspirin right so it
would be as if if you went down to one
aspirin you get no effect and if you
took two aspirins it would knock you out
so with the 40-minute intravenous
infusion Academy
it's really a very narrow window where
it really works and this is really
important because there are some
preparations that are being developed
that might be oral
where the whole point of the treatment
is to achieve a lower dose not to
achieve the kind of blood level that you
get with the 0.5 milligram per kilogram
intravenous dose we don't know if those
treatments are effective for various
conditions or not really at this point
but whatever they're doing they're not
doing what the traditional
antidepressant dose of ketamine is doing
so let me ask a few follow-up questions
well actually let me just maybe explain
for folks
if my audiences as I imagine a lot of
Yanks meaning Americans so kilogram
roughly 2.2 or maybe exactly 2.2
pounds so for me again this is not
perfect math I weigh about 170 175 let's
just call it roughly 80 kilograms
something in that range
for the 0.5
milligrams so half a milligram per
kilogram of body weight
what is the rate of infusion so if we're
talking about a 40 minute IV is it
equally distributed in other words is
each minute the first minute second
minute 13th minute 40th minute the same
amount or do you front load in some
capacity a bolus so that a larger
percentage of the total is administered
in the earlier phases of administration
it depends really whether it's a
clinical or research procedure so when
we do research with ketamine we give a
bolus and then a slow infusion to
maintain that peak level of ketamine
throughout the test period because this
gives us a a longer period of time where
the brain has a steady exposure for
ketamine where we can really
do brain Imaging studies or
psychological testing and things like
that
when you get a bolus Academy
it's like jumping into a cold pool of
water and one person told me he felt
like he was rocketed out of the universe
and he got a big bolus of right up
because you get the full effects within
about about 30 seconds or a minute of
the infusion whereas if you get the slow
infusion in the traditional way it's
like wading into a pool and so you
gradually gradually get the effects and
it's much
less disorienting for people people tend
to like that a little better
so is it from a clinical outcome
perspective
and just as a as an example for folks
because bolus may be a fancy word
if we say hypothetically since it's a
40-minute IV for the sake of making the
math simple let's say somebody weighs 40
kilograms so they're getting
0.5 milligrams per kilogram so that
would be 20 if I'm not screwing this up
20 milligrams total
right one option would be the 0.5
milligrams
every minute for 40 minutes and if it
were a bolus
certainly there are some clinics I've
observed
who might administer
20 or 30 percent of that total in the
first handful of minutes so my question
is for you putting the patient Comfort
aside which maybe a silly thing to do
well if we put patient Comfort aside
let's just say getting rocketed into a
different universe or out of the
universe is acceptable
if you're looking at clinical outcomes
with depressed patients
do you think there is a difference
between the the continuous
Administration The Waiting into the pool
versus the bolus in the beginning and if
you do use a bolus for a clinically
depressed patient
what does that potentially look like
just as a percentage of the total over
what period of time in the beginning
we don't have data to really inform us
but
in theory what we want to do is to get
up to a certain occupancy of the nmda
glutamate receptor and as far as I can
tell that's the critical thing so if we
get there quickly or if we get there a
little more slowly
so far it seems like both
have the potential to produce an
antidepressant response what is
different is that if you took the
infusion rate and doubled it
and so you said we're going to give you
the same and I think my math is correct
80 kilograms half a milligram per
kilogram would be 40 milligrams I'm
going to stick to my mission
if you took those 40 milligrams and you
infuse them over 80 minutes
then you would get the same total dose
but the peak blood level would be half
right and as far as we can tell that
would be more like giving a lower dose I
don't think that would be as effective
and that's because we think that the
antidepressant effects are kind of
triggered
by a relatively rapid change in
glutamate synaptic function
as opposed to a slower smaller more
gradual effect in glutamate function
is the choice for IV over say
intramuscular injection which is another
let's just call it common means of
administration at least by some
therapists or facilitators clinics Etc
what are the upsides and downsides of
that is it simply less predictable less
trackable the sort of pharmacokinetics
are
more erratic and therefore for a
scientific context it makes more sense
to do IV what are the pros and cons of
One Versus the other as far as I can
tell the main Pro of I am is ease in
other words you go up to somebody you
give them an injection and then it takes
care of itself you don't need an
intravenous line you don't need to wait
around
and so in some contexts that's a little
easier but the main drawback is that
with I am injections typically people
get the entire injection at once and
that's not optimal for everybody because
sometimes
when people get upset during academian
infusion or if they get a headache or if
they get nauseous or if they even start
to vomit we'll stop the infusion and
hold it and those side effects will go
away on their own but once you've given
the dose intramuscularly you can't take
it back yeah once you hit the golf ball
you can't unhit the golf ball exactly so
then you're counting on the person being
able to ride out whatever side effect
they get from the medication what are
some of the side effects in session and
how do you mitigate those side effects
for instance when I had my own
experience with
a series of infusions
it was standard operating procedure to
give I think it was eight milligrams or
so of Zofran so for sort of anti-nausea
so nausea does appear to be quite common
for folks but it can be attenuated with
some type of medication beforehand what
are some of the
more commonly observed side effects in
session and post session for that matter
and how do you attempt to address some
of those
the one that's probably most disturbing
to people is nausea
nobody likes to get nauseous nobody
likes to vomit
that I know of so this Zofran which is
an anti-nausea medication works pretty
well for most people
and the nausea that you get with
ketamine is a little bit like the spins
that you get if you drink too much I
don't know if it was for you but that
for some people that is the experience
that they describe and these are Fran
works pretty well for that medically
the side effect that people watch very
carefully is blood pressure so ketamine
produces a small increase in blood
pressure and if you start with an
elevation in your blood pressure before
you get ketamine it can boost your blood
pressure up in in a Range where
you wouldn't want it so
when that is a risk we pre-treat people
with a drug that blocks the beta
adrenergic receptor drug like
Propranolol and that works pretty well
those are the main side effects that we
have to manage people often think that
the main concern is the
the side effect of dissociation or
transient psychosis or cognitive
impairment and
the main way we manage that when we're
administering the drug intravenously is
by stopping the infusion
we can stop an infusion within 30
minutes a person is pretty much back to
themselves
even if they get the full dose the side
effects usually don't last that long and
in my experience of administering
ketamine a very large number of times
the main thing that's helpful is getting
right up to people and talking to them
so that they have a kind of visceral
sense of your presence there and
assuring them that they're going to be
okay and that this isn't going to last
because one of the things that can
happen during ketamine infusion is that
people lose the perspective that the
drug is causing the change in their
consciousness
and the best way to prepare people for
that is remarkably to prepare them for
that
so what we do before we give anybody
ketamine is spend a fair amount of time
telling them what ketamine effects could
be like
preparing them so they're not surprised
when it happens and then when it does
happen say if they happen to have a
prominent feeling of unreality or
changes in environmental perception or
perception of the body we tell them you
remember before the session we we talked
about how you might have these kinds of
effects
well it's happening and it's gonna go
and most people find that very
comforting because they kind of knew it
was going to happen all along and and
you tell them this is what we're talking
about it does change their frame of
reference but they usually tolerate it
pretty well that makes me remember
a sign that at one point was inside a
yurt at Burning Man which was associated
with something called zendo which is
sort of pure support harm reduction
mostly related to psychedelic use so if
people are having a difficult
psychedelic or drug experience their
friends will bring them to this yurt
where there will be sober sitters and
volunteers and managers and so on to
look after them and I don't think they
have it there anymore but there used to
be a sign huge sign on the wall where
everybody could see it that said
you took drugs and the good news is
they're working
exactly just a big reminder now let me
share a few things from from my
experience which I am sure
just to be clear format wise diverged
quite
a bit from what you are describing in
terms of best practices duration of IV
Etc and I chose a clinical setting for a
number of reasons and I think we'll come
back to a few of them one was I wanted
to make it as inconvenient as possible
for me to use ketamine so we're gonna
we'll come back to that the second was I
really
wanted to standardize the experience and
have the versatility that IV provides
which is not the case with hitting the
golf ball with intramuscular injections
so I wanted to be able to which I did
ultimately have the ability to dial up
the rate of administration
in the middle of say a
therapy conversation with a therapist
and then at one point I remember very
very clearly dialed up the rate by about
20 25 and suddenly things got very
strange and there seemed to be a
distinct lag between my thoughts my
mouth moving and me hearing any sound
which makes it very hard to talk it's
kind of like having a delayed Reverb on
a microphone or a set of speakers when
you're trying to talk it's extremely
challenging and I remember saying John
that was the name of the
technician or medic who a former medic
who was administering the ketamine I
said John things are getting a little
bendy could you please dial back and he
was able to dial back and then I could
resume the session and I I wanted that
type of ability to experiment
the session itself and this is where I'd
love to hear a bit about the setting the
session itself there was an intake
process and
I was in a room sitting in a comfortable
chair recliner effectively
big screen TV and you got to choose your
effectively let's call it a nature video
with scenes of nature with music
overlaid and I standardized on one
Redwood video
and and I should say that was the first
time I had ever watched a video in a any
type of
clinical or serious setting with with
Drug Administration so I found that in
and of itself quite novel
we can come back to the pros and cons of
that at some point
and my experience post session was
and we were gradually escalating dose I
mean starting well below let's just call
it the minimum effective dose that
you're outlining and then probably
exceeding it by quite a bit by the end
and my experience after the session
became a running joke with my girlfriend
because I would always forget something
at the clinic I would leave my wallet I
would forget my phone I would forget my
backpack I would come home I'd put
something somewhere forget where it was
and it seemed like my short-term memory
was just gone for a period of time and
that leads me to two questions so number
one
how common is that that one experienced
some cognitive deficit or short-term
memory impairment for a period of time
and what does the actual setting look
like in
the
clinical setups that you've supervised
or observed is it in a blank room are
they staring at the ceiling do they have
eye shades on are they listening to
music
Etc
I've seen all of the above
in terms of settings and
we've always used blank rooms partly
because
what we're trying to do is to make
ketamine available to as many people as
possible and have the most efficient
settings so in our Clinic which has led
co-led by uh Dr Robert ostroff and
Gerard Santa Cora both experts in this
work it would look like a surgical
recovery route with a number of bays and
everybody has their own space they're
shielded from seeing other people by
curtains and things like that so they do
have some privacy
but the doctors are moving and the
nursing staff are moving from Patient to
Patient to Patient in the session so it
it's more of a strange in some way
almost a communal
experience not that people are wanting
the communal experience per se but but
it is a very efficient way to deliver
the treatment one of the things about
ketamine is that it distorts perception
in exactly the way that you describe so
some groups try to keep the level of
stimulation limited because the more
intense the sensory input on ketamine
the more you get distortions
of the experience
and
it is said by mentors of mine who worked
the emergency rooms when when you would
get PCP and and LSD intoxicated people
come to the emergency room that the
management strategy was the opposite for
those two medications because PCP like
ketamine causes distortions of the input
so the more input that you get the more
distorted Things become but with LSD
there's almost like a battle for control
of your
perceptual world so when you put the
blinders on and produce sensory
deprivation you tend to augment the
intensity of LSD you're withdrawing the
organizing
effects of the sensory world and and so
you tend to have a little bit more
stimulation in the emergency room
setting with with the psychedelics than
you do with with PCP
is there let's see here well actually I
think you answered the question I was
going to ask you if if cost and scale
were no consideration I suppose I didn't
frame it this way for the purposes of
scaling it makes perfect sense that you
would want
the least cost
the least on some level least space
required at least training right you
don't want it to require a
four-string quartet or something
but if cost and scale were no
consideration do you have any thoughts
on how you might
design the setting would it be any
different I understand the point that
you made which I think probably applies
whether cost is a constraint or not
about minimizing inputs but do you have
any other thoughts on what that might
look like it's an interesting question
my general feeling about ketamine like
most clinical experiences is that when
the patient is comfortable and feels
well cared for and supported that
outcomes tend to be better so the whole
setting that you describe a really comfy
chair a really relaxing video
that's not too stimulating
privacy and quiet
is pretty close to an optimized setting
in the video mainly because
not much happens describing a treatment
where not much is happening during the
infusion if you're going to reactivate
trauma memories or if you're going to
reactivate alcohol memories that itself
is going to be a pretty engrossing
intervention and and probably will
occupy a lot of the kind of
sensory space of the infusion it sounds
like you had some version of that
well there the problem with video well
one of the many potential complications
with video is that
not all content may provoke the warm and
cozy feeling that you may be seeking so
I remember
watching for the first time this video
and it's like beautiful redwoods and
rivers kind of creepy not creepy but
like minor tone melancholic music which
I didn't love I didn't expect that or
see that coming but I was already kind
of strapped to the seat and on the ride
so I couldn't couldn't get off in the
middle of
Pirates of the Caribbean Disney World
ride so I was I was in it but I remember
at one point on a higher dose there's
this one scene that popped up out of
nowhere and it was just this it was this
fox this little fox it looked like maybe
it was Patagonia or something like that
it was just sitting on this freezing
cold Beach it was sitting on this sand
and it just looked miserable it wasn't
doing anything I was like why is this
fox here it looked really unhappy
that was not conducive to an optimal
clinical experience
let's talk not about necessarily the
side effects in session but some of the
risks of ketamine and I'm going to lead
into that in a few ways so one of the
apparent
prose one of the apparent benefits of
ketamine as contrasted to some other
drugs that people may have heard about
on this podcast let's just say Ayahuasca
as an example
there appear to be fewer Contra
indications for ketamine I'd love for
you to speak to that but there appear to
be fewer contraindications versus say
Ayahuasca plus SSRI could mean serotonin
syndrome possibly fatal certainly I
began with cardiac risk people die from
these things right in contrast to some
of these very powerful psychedelics
and there are certain psychedelics to be
fair psilocybin LSD being two of them
that seem to have almost no identifiable
ld50 from a physiological basis they
seem to be relatively low risk not true
psychologically perhaps but ketamine for
me has two huge advantages relative to
many other psychedelics number one there
are
legal options you can explore
that is non-trivial right legal options
you can explore which means you can
operate through in many cases regulated
vetted practitioners on some level
so the there there's a practitioner risk
that to a certain extent you can remove
if you're proactive about focusing on
that the second would be
contraindication risk
however one of the things I mentioned
earlier I want to come back to and that
was I wanted to make it as inconvenient
as possible for me to use ketamine
and the reason I decided to do that is
well there are multiple reasons the
first is
and most important is that I had seen
multiple friends and there are at least
a handful of friends right now I know of
who will fit this description
who had decided to stop using one
dissociative
anesthetic certainly at high enough
doses alcohol and switched to using
ketamine four or five nights a week
alcohol without the hangover and
I found this very deeply concerning and
certainly new friends were using
ketamine hundreds of times a year
in some cases and these are also to
paint a full picture experienced
Psychonauts with a lot of psychedelic
experience but psychedelics
and you see this in animal models as
well have a certain
for most people self-regulating or
self-limiting capacities I mean if you
give LSD to a rat in a bottle it hits it
once and it never touches it again
uh so I would love for you to speak to
some of the
risks of ketamine
maybe outside of the lab or even inside
of the lab and
[Music]
how you think about mitigating some of
those risks if there's addictive
potential speaking to that and out of my
own personal curiosity I would also be
fascinated no
is the behavior that I've seen in humans
The Addictive Behavior also found in
animal experiments or is it is it not
so first
I think your Point's really well taken
which is
that to think about a drug like ketamine
most people gravitate to the risks that
are the most flamboyant part of it in
other words what's the risk of
dissociation what's the risk of a
transient psychosis from single Doses
and to tell the truth I've found
that those risks are really quite
Limited
people have undersold
the addiction risk of Academia in the
United States but in some parts of the
world ketamine is known as a very
significant
commonly abused substance often as an
alternative to alcohol or sometimes as
an alternative to cannabis I visited
clinics where ketamine abuse was being
treated these were really heavy users of
ketamine they were hospitalized in
patient unit they were persistently
psychotic and those psychosis didn't
clear
even after a time when they had stopped
using the academy and so ketamine abuse
carries with it uh risks that have to be
taken very seriously all the way from
drunk driving
to really high dose Academy use we said
earlier that the typical therapeutic
dose for an 80 kilogram man was about 40
milligrams and in China and in Taiwan
I've met with people who were using
eight grams a day intranasally gnarly so
in other words that's 8 000 milligrams
that's a hundred fold or 200 full times
the dose and they used it every day
one of the things that that happens when
you use ketamine every day is that its
effects on the brain
turn out to be the opposite of the acute
effects so when we give a dose and we
let the brain react
the brain responds
in ways that are helpful we get regrowth
of synaptic connections we get
potentiation of synaptic function
and in animal studies there's some
evidence that the inhibitory cells which
are sometimes atrophied in depressed
patients will come back to life and all
kinds of beneficial effects happen and
while the effects of a single dose don't
seem to be permanent those are those are
all kinds of effects that we hope to see
and and and hopefully over time with
treatment will become stabilized and
when we space the doses apart we don't
get tolerance to the effects Academy we
don't have to give higher and higher
doses Academy and if anything the fact
that we can space it apart suggests that
the brain has become more responsive or
the brain's reaction to ketamine has in
some way adapted in a positive way
ketamine when you use ketamine regularly
when you use it every day it produces
the opposite pattern of adaptations
instead of becoming sensitized to the
effects of ketamine
and
having the ability to give doses that
are spaced farther and farther apart you
become tolerant to the effects Academy
you need more and more ketamine to
produce the same effects and people tend
to use the dose more and more frequently
so I've I've spoken to people who
started using ketamine to self-treat
their depression they would take it once
a month and that would initially
hold them just fine and then they take
it you know maybe if they were heading
into a stressful time and a stressful
weekend they would take an extra dose
before the weekend and maybe they were
having a down day they'd take an extra
dose Academy
and some of these people with the best
of intentions and no interest whatsoever
in in developing a ketamine habit found
themselves taking it more and more
frequently every day these were people
who were given bottles of ketamine to
use at home and who were who had the
ability to take it whenever they
whenever they needed and and some of
these people ended up taking it every
day and some of these people ended up
taking it four five six times a day in
order to maintain their equilibrium and
one of the things that that happens if
you take high doses of ketamine every
day as opposed to lower doses of
ketamine sporadically is that ketamine
can increase your vulnerability to
depression when used in this compulsive
manner as opposed to decreasing your
symptoms of depression and and if you
look at the brains of people who use
ketamine very regularly
they have
rather than enrichment of synaptic
connections they tend to have loss
reductions in white matter you know the
marker of neural Connections in the
brain on MRI in parts of the brain they
tend to have impaired function of the
brain
with functional magnetic resonance
imaging they tend to have cognitive
impairments and those cognitive
impairments tend not to resolve rapidly
when ketamine use is stopped but rather
have a very slow response and in some
cases there may be residual impairments
in memory or attention and then the most
extreme cases for this group of people
that are using extremely high doses
Academy for a long period of time you
have this risk of persisting psychosis
and as I mentioned earlier that's
particularly scary because these
persisting psychotic symptoms that you
see with lung high dose long-lasting
ketamine use they don't respond very
well to antipsychotic medications and
those psychotic symptoms don't
necessarily go away quickly when
ketamines uses stocks so ketamine is a
drug that has to be given a lot of
respect and and treated with a way that
recognizes that careful thought needs to
go into protecting people from
developing a problems related Academy
news
and in the group that people worry about
the most are people who have already not
only depression but some kind of
substance use disorder whether it be
alkal use disorder stimulants opiates
things like that and and that's a
problem in terms of access to ketamine
as an effective antidepressant because
out of this concern about the addiction
risk of ketamine or the risks of
ketamine for people with addiction
a lot of programs that would otherwise
be prescribing ketamine for the
treatment of of depression will exclude
people who have these substance use
disorders and that turns out to be a lot
of people who are depressed in the first
place so you're cutting out a large
group of of people and I believe and I
think others believe that there's a need
to really think about how what the
optimized way to treat these patients
who have depression and and comorbid
substance use disorders so one strategy
is the strategy that was developed
of by the group in England that I
mentioned earlier the University College
London where they're trying to activate
the drug memories during the ketamine
infusion to try to to counteract
whatever
aggravating effect ketamine might have
on addiction and in fact have produced
beneficial effects on on drug craving
the biggest step is to limit the
availability of ketamine to the clinic
setting and that that protects people
not only from
developing
taking more and more ketamine on their
own but it also helps to limit the
possibility that the ketamine that
they're given would be diverted to
others who wanted to use it for
recreational purposes and that's really
that's really something that needs to be
thought about really carefully because
let's say a person got a bottle of
ketamine that had a thousand milligrams
of it or let's say they got appeals of
ketamine that had a a thousand
milligrams because a thousand milligrams
might not be that many oral doses
because your body metabolizes
ketamine so rapidly that if you give it
early you have to give a lot and so
giving a thousand milligrams might not
be that much for someone who was just
going to use it orally but what if they
gave that a thousand milligrams to
someone who was going to dissolve it and
administer it intravenously
person can get high on maybe 10
milligrams yeah or stored it or snort it
exactly so you've just given the person
who maybe just got a few doses of oral
ketamine all of a sudden maybe just got
like 100 doses of intravenous ketamine
so the risks of diversion when you when
you give
ketamine
to people for home use you have to
really be you know thoughtful and
careful about thinking about that and
there are a variety of interesting
strategies to deal with this so for
example there's a company out there
that's developing intranasal delivery
system to deliver controlled substances
in a manner that has
less risk wait how do they decrease the
risk with the nasal Administration is it
like a child proof lock that just locks
it for a period of time or how does it
work it's sort of a more elaborate
version where there's some external
regulation of the dosing and external
monitoring of the dosing so the person
only is able to use it to administer the
ketamine at certain times it's not for a
hundred percent protection but it but
for most people it would be very
protective against the diversion of
Academy another strategy is to try to
develop
a ketamine that is less got less abuse
potential
so a company that that I've been working
with called freedom biosciences is
trying to do just that by combining
ketamine with a drug that might reduce
its
abuse liability to come up with a
version of ketamine that
has less abuse risk associated with it
and that's still early days with that
but it's it's an interesting idea so on
that last point and we don't have to get
into any specifics you don't want to get
into but is it is it by changing the
ketamine itself or is it by lowering the
minimum effective dose required of
ketamine by combining it with other
drugs so there are a variety of
companies that are
approaching a variety of different
strategies to try to get to this point
so for example one company that believes
that their version of ketamine has a
less abuse liability is using the
opposite isomer in other words the mere
image of s ketamine is called R ketamine
and so they believe that that that
version of ketamine might have less
intrinsic abuse liability
there are other drugs that block the
nmda receptor that are being explored or
being developed for the treatment of
depression that may or may not have
similar degrees of abuse liability with
with ketamine there's the strategy that
freedom is trying which is combining an
anti-addiction medication with ketamine
to reduce its abuse risk so there are a
variety of strategies that people are
taking to try to reduce this risk
because in many ways abuse is the
greatest risk associated with the with
ketamine ketamine has been around since
the 60s it's medically safe and well
tolerated by most people when given in
the in the way in which it's given for
treatment we don't see much evidence of
of persisting medical risk the only
persisting medical risk that we can't
prevent is the one when people are
developing addiction so we want to think
about ways to broaden the pool of people
who would be considered for ketamine and
and maybe to take advantage of the fact
that that treating depression is good
for addiction just like treating
addiction is good for depression so
priding an Avenue for the safe treatment
of these patients we think is really
important
I wonder if there is a drug and there
may be I just I just don't know my my
biochemistry and my pharmacopia but if
there's a drug that would increase the
nausea and other undesirable side
effects of ketamine in between sessions
and therefore act as a biological
policing function of sorts because I
know these drugs exist for other things
for other compounds but it's just I'm
allowing my mind to go wild with all the
different options I mean there are a lot
of different options here let me let me
come back to the
the animal model question for a second
or the animal testing model because
it's sometimes easy to forget that
humans are not just really large mice in
fact we are quite different
our addictive properties of ketamine
observed in animal use or
self-administration or is that
seemingly unique to higher primates or
humans who have all of the
sort of attendant weaknesses of
let's just call it higher functioning
and
neuroses and so on is the abuse
witnessed in animals it's a great
question and what's interesting is that
there are some drugs of abuse
Like Cocaine that animals love
and humans seem to like as well right
but ketamine is more like alcohol so
there are some strains of rodents that
naturally consume alcohol and or
naturally consume ketamine but generally
speaking you have to kind of gradually
introduce them to alcohol or to ketamine
and then they can become compulsive
alcohol consumers or academian consumers
just like humans and it's bad and the
animal models vary between very patient
you know escalation of alcohol or
ketamine and you give it to them at
times when they're most active like in
the dark and the road mice and rats are
more active in the dark and you give it
a little bit and you take it away and
then the animals will when you give them
ax this again they'll drink a little
more take a little more
and so they go through bouts of exposure
to the drug and then they tend to
develop more heavier versions of alcohol
or ketamine self-administration those
Health Administration ketamine they'll
self-administer PCP
and other substances from that class
I was speaking with an acquaintance who
was commenting on a few subcultures I
won't name them but a few subcultures in
the US that seem to
use
ketamine
extensively as a drug of abuse and he
said if anyone claims they're not
addicted to ketamine ask if you can
borrow their look at their inhaler for a
second or their their insufflater their
nasal applicator and just stick it in
your pocket and see how long it takes
them to get really agitated
and sort of insist on getting it back
like schmeagle from Lord of the Rings
and I will also just add one
comment which is
I think it is very dangerous for people
to say or believe or assume
I do not have an addictive personality
therefore this is not a risk because my
feeling based on all my experience there
is a molecule that will get you there is
a molecule that will get you so I think
an ounce of prevention is worth a pound
of cure for sure in this instance and
many of my friends
who are experienced Psychonauts at least
a few of them had no prior
abuse history with with any drugs
outside of in this case ketamine
so let's talk about you mentioned the
R ketamine versus acetamine right and
there are a lot of urban myths from Avid
consumers of ketamine as to the
differences between these two and who
knows maybe they know what they're
talking about I think most of them are
just bullshitting frankly but good at
storytelling and that's their new way of
showing off is talking about how deep
their expertise in in ketamine
consumption goes as connoisseurs but
this is just a a question that I'm sure
I will embarrass myself in asking so
you're talking about our ketamine versus
S ketamine and is it right to say
they're kind of mirror images they're
like enantiomers is that the word I'm
probably pronouncing it incorrectly
you've got it you got the linger all
right so just for people who are not
looking at video on the audio what I'm
doing is I'm holding up both of my hands
open Palms facing me so thumbs pointing
different directions another way to
think of it would be like the state of
Michigan the glove flip it the other way
okay so we have these two mirror images
but then I'm thinking to myself wait a
second well these are not 2D images
these are three-dimensional molecules so
if I rotated one of my hands 180 degrees
would they not be the same thing so I'm
just very confused by this right and
left-handed
shorthand that is sometimes used to
describe the differences in these two
because it it seems like well if I
flipped one 180 degrees you would have
effectively the same molecule
the same series of hydrogens and carbons
or configuration would they not bind in
exactly the same way could you just shed
some light on that well first
I think you do a great job of portraying
the RNs in the engineers that was very
impressive
fact but secondly you said something
which is extremely important which is
that what really counts for these
molecules binding to the nooks and
crannies is the three-dimensional space
so what you couldn't portray is that
when you overlaid your two hands in a
way that made the sequence of the
molecules in the two in the two isomer
cylinder was that in one case
the first carbon might be sticking into
the plane but in the other case the
carbon was sticking out of the plane
right and so that when you saw the
actual structure in three-dimensional
space they actually
occupied them in ways they couldn't beat
one where you couldn't superimpose one
on the other they're actually turning in
opposite directions and and that turns
out to make a big difference because
are ketamine
is somewhere between three and five
times less potent in its ability to
block what we think is the primary
target of ketamine in the brain which is
the nmda glutamate receptor and
it's a really complicated story too too
complicated for us to to go into in
detail but the reality is that there are
at least four
subtypes of nmda glutamate receptors and
ketamine binds with a little bit
different Affinity to each of the four
types of The nmda receptors and the fact
that there's that differential affinity
for ketamine has been taken up by the
Pharmaceuticals industry where you have
different companies developing
alternatives to ketamine that Target us
just a subtype of the nmda glutamate
receptor to Black and that's a whole
other area that's being developed by the
by the pharmaceutical industry but we go
back to R versus S John May interrupt
for one second so when people just say
ketamine
is that
a third molecular configuration versus R
and S or
is it just a lazy shorthand that is
omitting one of those so when people say
ketamine these days they're talking
about the mixture of the r and the S
molecules I say so the standard
Academy that we studied was a mixture of
R and S and when people say s ketamine
which is the version of ketamine that
was developed
by Jansen Pharmaceuticals that's the S
isomer which is more potent at blocking
the nmda glutamate receptor the idea
being ketamine has a more potent and
less potent blocker let's develop a
treatment that blocks the nmda receptor
more potently and the logic goes
something like then we can give less
total dose
and maybe that'll be safer in terms of
side effects or better in terms of
tolerability
the alternative idea which is being
developed
in relation to our ketamine is
still I'd say from where I sit which is
a bit at a distance from the Art Academy
is
one of two strategies and it's not clear
to me which strategy will be followed
one strategy says
our ketamine has a different
binding profile at nmda receptors and
other targets and so the ratio of its
affinity for nmda versus these targets
is different than us Academy
so if we bring our ketamine up to the
same dose as s ketamine the same
comparable occupancy of nmda receptors
maybe it'll be a little bit more
tolerable
the alternative idea is
what if our ketamine Works through some
other Target
maybe it doesn't work through the nmda
receptor in which case you might be able
to get some kind of effectiveness at a
low dose that doesn't produce
dissociative effects you know that would
be if it really is just as effective as
s-ketamine and doesn't produce addiction
liability and doesn't produce
dissociative effects and doesn't have
other medical effects that would be
super but the problem is if our ketamine
is working by some other mechanism
what is it
how does it work does it have any of the
properties that we ascribe to racemic RS
ketamine at lower nmda receptor
occupancy and the answer there is we
have no idea
so as our ketamine gets developed you
know it has shown Effectiveness in
animal models
in in studies in Japan by Kenji
Hashimoto and some other groups so
there's interest in our ketamine and how
it should be dosed and what it would be
like and it's still kind of getting
sorted out but it's really important to
understand that there's a way to use our
ketamine that's not that different than
the way we currently use as Academy and
then there's a way to use our ketamine
that's some kind of lower dose
lower dose
treatment that if it works
would be working through some other
pathway that we don't yet understand
so I have a few things just to
bookmark for folks or mentioned for
folks and then I have a question about
other applications of ketamine because I
would be remiss if I didn't mention my
own personal
experience but first I just want to talk
about a bit of trivia
people should look up another piece of
trivia the origin the etymology of the
word trivia
three roads meeting in any case people
should look it up it's pretty fun
separately
I have read
a theory a description of a theory that
has
has postulated that the origin of
human tendency to alcohol abuse
originates from from our Simeon
ancestors who would find fruit that was
fermenting and consequently become
somewhat intoxicated but that it was an
evolutionary
driver it was a a fitness advantage for
natural selection to be able to not just
identify and find fermenting fruit but
to consume it and to be inclined to
consume it so I I don't know if there's
any scientific consensus or acceptance
of this but relatively recently came on
my radar which I thought was at least
interesting as a thought exercise
the the application
potential application I'd like to get
your two cents on the scientific support
for this that I experienced firsthand
was going in for my series of ketamine
infusions which just as a comedic side
note
in these intake
questionnaires they would always ask you
know anxiety on a scale of one to ten
and I mean starting from nothing
what I always do with these one to ten
questionnaires because how the hell do
you know I on some level I mean if it's
if it's a pain scale I think it's a
little bit easier right it's like okay
one is I can't feel it 10 is I need to
go to the emergency room immediately
okay fine but on the anxiety I always
choose five if it's the first session
for anything I choose five so that I can
go above or below on subsequent intake
forms and
I was doing I think it was three a week
and I was I was coming in without any
depression at the time
but I I had a packed schedule of podcast
recording and so my anxiety kept going
up over time because it was
screwing up my ability to prepare for
the podcast because my short-term memory
was Vanishing and the the nurse
practitioner said I've never seen
anything like this you just keep getting
worse and I'm like well it's not the
full picture but yeah that's fine
however what I did realize about a week
after my two weeks of infusions
chronic pain that I'd had on my the left
side of my thoracic region of my back
had completely vanished and
it remained gone for probably
five or six months minimum and it was
the first time in my adult life that I
had gone pain-free for that period of
time
with this this thoracic
carryover from a severe injury many many
years ago
is there much
published literature to support
using ketamine and I don't know if this
I would imagine is related to nmda
receptors to reboot or otherwise treat
chronic pain the answer is yes there are
two kind of interesting parts of this
one is The nmda receptors are are in the
pain Pathways there it's in the spinal
cord The nmda receptors are in the
spinal cord and involved in transmitting
the pain messages up to the brain and
they're in the higher executive pain
centers like in the thalamus very dense
in the thalamus and so it both can
reduce the experience of pain and it can
reduce how much pain is upsetting to you
so so in both ways ketamine can be
helpful via its action in blocking the
nmda glutamate receptors and it's now
being already used commonly in pain
centers for the treatment of
pathological pain
there's another part of ketamine that
from the pharmacology point of view is
extremely interesting
and this goes back to the work of Keith
Trujillo and Huda Akil
maybe in the 90s I think in the late 90s
and what they found is that
you could prevent the development of
Tolerance
to the anti-pain effects of opiates by
co-administering ketamine or an nmda
antagonist I think they used a different
one
intermittently during the exposure to
opiates and so one of the big problems
as you know with opiates they're very
helpful for controlling pain for many
people but if you have like you know
neuropathic pain old Sports Injury back
pain or you know and you get that kind
of chronic grading nerve pain
sometimes people will be on opiates for
a long time and they're not really
getting much benefit from those drugs
and so nmda antagonists can be a path
for reducing the pain that can't be
reduced by the opiates and restoring
sensitivity to the opiates
so that people don't need to use so much
opiates to control their pain afterwards
and
the third thing that ketamine can do
that's really interesting
is prevent the sensitization of pain
Pathways so let's say you're going to
have a knee replacement and you know
that when you have a knee replacement
you know you're going to do some things
to the nurse to make it possible to
replace the knee and
and that there's a risk for some chronic
pain related to that knee replacement
as you know because you just said it
ketamine interferes with neuroplasticity
and and while the ketamine is in your
system can interfere with the encoding
and the neuroadaptations associated with
memory and so I produce a some temporary
memory impairment well it does the same
thing for learning in the pain pathway
yeah so if you pre-treat people with
ketamining have ketamine in their system
when they undergo the the knee
replacement the chances that they're
going to develop this nagging
long-lasting pain in neuropathic pain
goes down so it's very common to have a
drug like ketamine given during an
operation like that to reduce the
development of neuropathic pain so it
can be used to treat pain and to prevent
I mean what I found most incredible
about the experience was the durability
of the pain relief this is not a
scientific explanation because I haven't
done the proper homework to be able to
speak to that but it seemed like there
are certain motor patterns that we learn
to associate with pain even if the
mechanical dysfunction or damage has
ceased to be an issue right now in the
case of my mid-back there are actually
some spinal issues but let's just say
you do a squat you blow out your knee
and then for six months it hurts to
squat after that point mechanically
you're intact but you have learned that
a certain motor pattern
is dangerous and so your body
delivers a learned pain signal in some
capacity it seems like
at least to me that there was
as you mentioned a learned
aspect to this that was over sensitizing
and that that was rebooted or disabled
with the use of ketamine maybe to use a
different analogy or metaphor for folks
like imagine that if you got severely
sunburned after the sunburn had passed
you would retain a certain sensitivity
to the Sun an oversensitivity as a like
prophylactic learned
precautions that you would not get
sunburned again you know something like
that it's not the best comparison but
you get the idea
how do you explain the durability
of the effects because the the half-life
Academy it's long gone
pretty quickly
but the pain relief I mean complete pain
relief it wasn't 10 better it was a
hundred percent better lasted at least
six months and that that I found just
staggering
how do you explain that
well that's a great question I don't
know that I can explain six months but
what I can't say is
so the first thing you said which was
that your whole body adapted to having
pain in in your knee
and you change the way that you moved in
ways that were probably
sparing acute pain but were probably a
burden and maybe not good for your
overall health
the second thing I would say is that
there's a close tie between depression
and anxiety and and pain and a lot of
what we're managing when we're managing
pain is our emotional response to the
pain and if you tone down the depression
and anxiety
then you discover that the pain is
actually much more manageable
because anxiety and depression focuses
our attention on pain and makes us
vulnerable to blowing the pain out of
proportion it's not that we don't feel
the pain more intensely but we feel the
pain more intensely because our
attention tends to get drawn in such a
focused way to it and so
I think that there are many levels where
and many potential ways the
neuroplasticity part of it the
depression and anxiety cognitive part of
it
the ability to engage
a variety of strategies to suppress the
pain signals through relaxation and
other kinds of techniques so
I think chronic pain is like depression
or PTSD in that it's often useful to
think about being resilient to the pain
as opposed to making
whether or not you have it or not so I
think what one of the things that you're
describing is that ketamine helped you
to be resilient in the face of a
potential source of pain and and so that
you live the life of a person who didn't
have pain
and you discovered that when you did
that
you didn't have pain
yeah I like the comparison to PTSD I
mean you can imagine and this is
getting into an entire different uh
class of the I guess it's not really a
phenethylene that would be more MDA but
if we're looking at MDMA assisted
Psychotherapy for PTSD
the memory is the same right the the
traumatic experience and the memory
thereof may be the same but it's how you
contextualize it and relate to it
that seems to contribute to the
diagnosis or non-diagnosis of PTSD it's
not a perfect comparison but certainly
the sort of phenomenology the the
subjective experience that is reported
by many patients is that they were able
to go back revisit this memory that
would normally be re-traumatizing or
make them hyper reactive and produce
this huge physiological response and
calmly engage with it as their present
day self as sort of an observer to
metabolize it such that it doesn't have
that complete grip it's not consuming
for them afterwards
and just by comparison in the same way
that if somebody has acute pain I know
that when when I've had acute pain in my
mid back
it dominates everything I mean it is it
is the background color of anything that
is written upon it in my mind and so to
have that removed was just incredible
Let's uh let's hop we talked about R
ketamine here's one that I don't know
anything about but it's it's in some
notes so I would love to
I hear you
describe in any capacity s methadone
what is s methadone s methadone is yet
another drug that blocks nmda glutamate
receptors and is a drug that has some
potential to treat depression
the other isomer of methadone is the
methadone that we associate with opiate
mean so this is the inactive isotherm
methadone which works by blocking nmda
glutamate receptors and and there's some
preliminary data that's encouraging for
the treatment of depression you know
it's really important that you know we
have many different drugs that block the
ssris and it's been helpful to have a
portfolio of medications because for one
reason or another one of the family of
the ssris will be tolerable or will work
or won't work for one patient versus
another and and it'll probably be the
case
with nmda glutamate receptor antagonists
that ketamine works for some people and
some people that don't like the side
effects they they go to another nmda
receptor antagonist and maybe that one
will work so that that's a drug that has
some potential in that regard hmm coming
back to S ketamine versus R ketamine and
this is a simplistic question but I'm
wondering
if s ketamine is a more potent
Agonist
if I am getting my terminology straight
does that mean that s ketamine has at
the same dose as our ketamine more abuse
potential I'm wondering if if one or the
other appears to have or hypothetically
should have more abuse potential
so the animal data with our ketamine
have been pretty encouraging about abuse
potential but we don't have enough
experience in in humans to really be
able to say
as ketamine it's true that it's more
potent at the nmda receptor it's also a
little bit more potent at the MU opiate
receptor than our ketamine and and so
there's been some discussion about the
abuse liability
of ascetamine that's because of the MU
opiate receptor effect or I think it's
both okay there's been a tendency to be
more concerned about the MU opiate
receptor activity
than the nmda receptor antagonist
activity but in my view that's a bit of
a distraction because ketamine s
ketamine is much more potent at nmda
receptors than atmiopia receptors at
least it's more potent right yeah
several fold to maybe tenfold somewhere
in between there but clearly we all know
about addiction risks of opiates
but we want to make sure we don't
underestimate the addiction risks of our
ketamine s ketamine s methadone whatever
the nmd antagonist is
you know the rate of ketamine use
disorders has been going up since the uh
about 2018 or so in the United States so
we do want to be careful about that
yeah I wonder how how much that is also
correlated to just general increases in
diagnosed we have to be a little careful
about
assuming that all these things are on an
upswing not referring to ketamine abuse
but just because the detection or
reporting or diagnosis can also
become a trend in itself right if you
develop better technology for scanning
and identifying brain tumors lo and
behold brain tumors appear to be
exploding but it doesn't mean their
prevalence wasn't the same beforehand in
any case what I was going to say is it
seems like with the Advent of social
media and
the sort of social proof approval
culture that is so heightened by those
tools
it just it seems to me and this is also
watching my audience that the
prevalence of just chronic anxiety
depression certainly we saw during covid
a sharp increase in in suicide hotline
volume I wonder if ketamine and maybe
alcohol abuse are also correlated
because people are just looking away to
numb themselves to turn off certain
feelings I don't know
the answer to that
but you know I wanted to mention one
thing which which is the only other
apart from alcohol and if I'm being
honest I don't really know how alcohol
exerts its effects on the psyche and the
subjective experience but the only other
dissociative that I have some
familiarity with is salvan RNA which is
a high efficacy Kappa opioid receptor
Agonist and I'm wondering to what extent
the dissociative effects of ketamine are
dependent on that opiate receptor
interaction versus
other receptors
so let's backtrack and talk about these
three four compounds first alcohol
so alcohol is a ethanol is a weak nmda
glutamate receptor
antagonist and and that we think is a
major contributor about why the
subjective effects of a low enough dose
of ketamine are often described like
similar to a glass of wine and if you
get your alcohol dose High Enough
let's say it's been reported that you
can get numbing uh distortions
impairments and cognitions et cetera et
cetera as we all know and some of those
effects are thought to be similar in
fact we did a study where we gave
ketamine to very experienced alcohol
users who described
the antidepressant dose of ketamine as
similar on average to somewhere between
six and ten drinks of alcohol
yeah quite a few depending on the time
frame exactly so as a result of our
interests in this nmda opiate
interaction we did a study where we gave
people
a high dose of Naltrexone before we gave
them a dose Academy okay could you
explain what Naltrexone is I mean I know
what it is but yep an opiate receptor
blocker at low doses it preferentially
blocks the MU opiate receptor the
morphine receptor at higher dose if you
give a high dose it also blocks the
Delta opiate receptor which is the main
target or amine Target for the
incaffolds endogenous opiates and then
if you give an even higher dose of
Naltrexone you also block the Kappa
opioid receptor which is the salvinurine
receptor yep so if we give a pretty high
dose of Naltrexone and give ketamine we
don't change the dissociative effects of
ketamine at all you do not do not not at
huh wow what we do is we tend to make a
low dose of ketamine Less Pleasant for
people they get a little more anxious
they don't like it as much but they
don't it doesn't block the dissociative
effects now salvanorin if you give it
it's a very short acting drug in humans
my colleague Cyril de Souza and mohini
raganathan
dosed salvanorin and you can get this
very intense kind of psychedelic state
in in people that is relatively short
lasting what's interesting
about salvanorin is
it's not such a positively euphoric
experience as you get
people who uniformly rate
even if they don't like the experience
they still rate the ketamine experiences
as euphorogenic and they still rate a
lot of the Psychedelic the salvadora
tends to be highly dysphoric most people
will say I never ever in my life want to
do that again but what's so interesting
is that it shuts down
dopamine related reward signaling and
some reward processing in parts of the
brain and so
as we think about things like mood and
addiction
all of the systems that we've talked
about end up being implicated the nmda
glutamate receptor and synaptic
connection and the the Kappa opiate
receptor is thought to contribute to
some of the anhedonic symptoms of
depression the inability to feel Joy
yeah inability to feel Joy and my
brother who's a psychiatrist you know my
family history my father was a
psychiatrist and psychoanalyst my mother
became a social worker my brother is a
psychiatrist my cousin's a psychiatrist
I come from a genetically High
vulnerability family for mental health
professionals my daughter's becoming a
psychiatrist
and uh anyway so my brother did a study
as part of a Consortium
and gave
a Kappa opiate receptor Blocker in other
words the reverse of Salvadoran and
looked at the effects on brain circuit
activity and anhedonia in patients with
depression and showed that you could
affect the reward circuit activation
and reduce anhedonia in depressed
patients with this kind of mechanism a
Kappa opiate antagonist and so people
are actually interested in the Kappa
opioid receptor blockers as potential
treatments for some aspects of
depression it's super interesting yeah I
will say
just to also put Salvador RNA in context
that more people may
recognize Salvador and a isolated from
a ethno medical plant called Salvia
divinorum that's been used by indigenous
populations certain indigenous
populations like the mazatex for
hundreds probably thousands of years
and
before you ever touch this stuff go on
YouTube and search smoking salvia
divinorum and you will see dozens of
videos of people who thought it was a
good idea to set up a camcorder or an
iPhone before they did such a thing and
they will try to escape by running into
walls smashing through Windows flipping
over couches because they're so
terrified of this experience so just uh
the more you know Smokey the Bear
definitely think about it at least 37
times before you uh casually partake in
in any of these things
okay with that
thank you for providing all that context
so fascinating to me let's see here
going from
risk of scheduling to alternatives to
ketamine or
compliments possibly right not
necessarily replacements for but
depending on the subpopulation what
works and what doesn't work let's talk
about ways to optimize ketamine
what are some of the means by which we
might extend the efficacy improve the
safety
wherever you want to take that what are
some of the potential ways or future
ways to go about optimizing ketamine
let's start with the end if you will
which is what do we really want in
treatment what would be the ideal
antidepressant the ideal antidepressant
would be a drug that
acted rapidly and lasted forever
right we would call that basically cure
and we never use the word cure in
psychiatry
and we don't even think of the idea of
cure
and that's partly because we don't
really understand the brain well enough
to really know how to
completely undo the the changes that we
see there
so let's start just with a the shortest
version of that which is what if we
could
take
ketamine which has a short duration of
antidepressant effectiveness at the
beginning somewhere between say three
and seven days and make it last two
weeks or a little bit longer and you
might say well why would you think that
that would be a reasonable
thing to try to do
it's because when you give ketamine
to patients in the long run
you can space out the treatments more
and more in other words you start with
giving it twice a week then you go to
once a week then you go to every other
week and then eventually many people
will get to every three weeks or maybe
even every four weeks so
it suggests that there are some
mechanisms
that are
triggered when we give ketamine or
existing as a precondition for treatment
resistant depression
that shortened the duration of the
effectiveness Academy
and so we've been interested in that
question for a long time and when we did
a study
that really spurred our interest in this
question and it was led at our site by
my colleague chadi Abdullah and what we
did was to try to block a certain
molecular switch that gets triggered
when you give Academy
Downstream
one of the proteins that gets activated
inside nerve cells that triggers the
regrowth of those synaptic connections
that protein is called mtor and the drug
we use to manipulate it is called
rapamycin it's a block or ventor now
you'll recall from the animal studies
that mtor activation was implicated in
the antidepressant effects Academy
so we did a study to try to show that
that was somehow involved in humans we
gave
the highest dose of rapamycin the mtor
blocker
that we felt would be perfectly well
tolerated by everybody in the study
rapamycin is an immunosuppressing drug
and that was in our mind as well for a
reason that I'm going to come back to in
a little bit so we gave rapamycin with
ketamine
so in the same group of 20 patients with
treatment resistant depression they
completed one ketamine day where they
got just ketamine
plus Placebo of course and then the
other day they got ketamine plus rhaps
and
the remarkable thing was that the
response rate at two weeks when they got
just Academy
was about 13 percent
and when they got the same people the
same depression if they had gotten
pre-treated with rapamycin their
response rate was over 40 percent I'm no
scientist but that seems non-trivial it
seemed to us to be non-trivial it was
also a little bit perplexing
in the sense that we knew we were giving
a drug
that had the potential to block mtor in
the brain and if mtor activation was
critical then why
didn't rapamycin block the
antidepressant effects Academy
and one of the ideas that we are
wrestling with is maybe the
immunosuppressive effects of rapamycin
which is a power is a powerful
immunosuppressant are related to its
ability to extend the antidepressant
effects Academy
and in particular
you may recall that I said that the
antidepressant affects the ketamine at
least in animals seem to last about as
long as the newly created synapses
and so we assume that as those synapses
are being gobbled up
that the antidepressant effects are
going away so what is doing the gobbling
up
it turns out that one of the critical
mechanisms that gets engaged are the
primary immune cells in the brain and
these Tim I think are maybe your new
favorite cells the microglia I'm
fascinated by microglia I just like
saying it too but yes microglia please
continue yeah so microglia are really
interesting because they have different
modes of function in certain
circumstances they can promote nerve
growth in the brain in another
circumstances when synapses get
immunologically tagged they can
surround them and literally
eat them up in fact over development
there are certain programmed ways that
synapses are eliminated and microglia
are involved in that but when you have
inflammation in the brain as you do in
depression microglia are involved and
then we think they contribute to the
initial deficits in synaptic density and
depression our microglia
correlated or is there a causal
relationship between our subjective
experience of stress and microglia
activity yes so microglia tend to be
activated under conditions of severe
and persisting stress like you have in
depression
the paradox
and I don't want to get us too
distracted because frankly I don't I
don't understand what we found
so I can't really explain it but in
patients with post-traumatic stress
disorder
we find both impatience while they're
alive with pet scanning and in analyzing
post-mortem brain tissue that the
microglia are suppressed and I've been
talking to
colleagues about this and they think
well maybe at one point they were
activated but maybe there's kind of in a
burned out State you know an exhaust is
microwear tired they're on the bench out
of the game exactly something like that
you know I don't really know and I don't
think anybody does what's what's going
on with the microglia but it's it's
really interesting to me that you have
these two stress-related disorders one
like major depression where the where
you get a lot of cortisol in the body
and the microglia tend to be activated
in the brain and then you get the
opposite pattern in PTSD where you don't
tend to get so much cortisol chronically
and you don't tend to get so much
microglia activation chronically so
we've stumbled onto something that we
think is important that's different in
these disorders that we don't yet quite
understand
but for the antidepressant effects
Academy
what we think is happening is that we
might be preventing the microglia from
gobbling up the newly created synapses
and so instead of lasting a couple of
days we get you know like a full course
of treatment how long does rapamycin
extend the the antidepressant effects
Academy we don't know the answer to that
because
since we didn't expect to see it we only
designed the study with a two-week
window of follow-up so we'll have to do
you know longer studies to figure that
out but we're really interested in
developing this idea both from the point
of view of academic research and I have
a colleague that I've collaborated with
for many years
Tom Sue in
in Taipei who is doing a study looking
at this combination and then we're
developing a version of this idea one
that we think may be optimized for use
in the treatment environment within a
company
called the freedom biosciences that I'm
associated with
touching again on the
rapamycin plus ketamine
certainly people can go on PubMed and
search mtor and ketamine and there are a
lot of there's a lot to read
if you haven't published this then of
course no need to no need to get into it
or if you don't want to disclose it
that's fine too but what was the
what was the dosage range that you
decided upon or maybe these precise
dosage or protocol for the rapamycin
that you determined or hypothesized to
be well tolerated
gosh I think it's six milligrams six
milligrams oh rapamycin and we may have
stumbled onto something by giving that
dose and what I mean by that is that
we thought it should get into the brain
at six milligrams and we were pretty
confident that it would get in the brain
it would have some effect in the brain
but rapamycin turns out to be actively
pumped out of the brain
and so the concentration that we
achieved was probably kept quite Low by
this active clearance mechanism and so
what we think we did was to stumble on a
combination that was in a kind of sweet
spot
high enough to interfere with uh
gobbling up of the synapses but not so
hard to interfere with the
antidepressant effects so a little bit
of serendipity
I feel like a lot of science is uh
Serendipity and knowing when to pay
attention to it seems like that's
one of the more exciting pieces of
scientific discovery is being able to
spot those serendipities that matter let
me ask uh
actually just mentioned something please
fact check me if I'm not getting this
correctly but
first I want to emphasize what you said
and that is that rapamycin is an
immunosuppressant and at higher doses
than we're discussing
are used for for instance organ
transplants and things along those lines
was the frequency of administration of
the oral rappa at five milligrams was
that once a week where you or
less was it a one-time Administration
how frequent in the intervention group
I don't know what the arms were in the
study but uh exactly but how frequently
would any one individual receive that
rapamycin so first Tim I think the point
that you make about
this is a experimental procedure it's
not really not ready for prime time
the finding hasn't even been replicated
yet you know this is what you do and
you're trying to develop a new treatment
and
you know it's very preliminary data in
some ways even though it's a very robust
finding but
it was just a single dose of rapamycin
given okay got it with that single dose
of ketamine and that was what was so
striking to us because rapamycin lasts a
little longer than ketamine but it
doesn't last
two weeks so really the possibility that
there's some Synergy between the two
treatments is really uh possibility
from the preliminary findings
it's very exciting it's very exciting
and the reason I ask is that
for people listening
as you said this is a powerful drug you
have to be very careful with it
you cannot just gobble this stuff like
Tic Tacs and expect to turn out well and
my very primitive understanding is that
if one were taking rapamycin as a
monotherapy for say life extension which
is very I mean I don't want to call it
very speculative but it's it's certainly
not main uh mainstream at this point or
for other purposes
my very cursory understanding is that
you're trying to have an effect on mtor
such that you trigger certain things
like autophagy and
sort of cellular Cleaning and Repair but
not so much that you bleed into I think
it's mtorq 2 territory where you start
to really experience the
immunosuppressant effects because you
then run the risk of
greater likelihood of infection if you
become infected greater severity of
infection you have to be very careful
with it
so in any case a fascinating fascinating
drug in case people were wondering
rapamycin named after Rapa Nui which is
the native
term applied to Easter Island
where the bacterium I guess was first
isolated that relates to M2 are pretty
fascinating stuff but let me also just
ask a novice question about
microglia and glial cells I assume
they're related
but the description I read of the glial
cells is that they're in a sense the
connective tissue of the nervous system
they provide physical and metabolic
support to neurons
how do you think about ensuring that the
sort of zambonis of the brain are able
to do what they need to do
while potentially inhibiting microglia
enough to get
these types of clinical outcomes that
you're hoping for yeah this has been one
of the most intriguing parts of the
ketamine work and it is again one of the
most intriguing parts of the rapamycin
work which is that
in both cases
we're not trying to produce a chronic
state of intoxication with ketamine and
we're not trying to produce a chronic
state of exposure to rapamycin we want
the zambonis to clean up the ice we want
the microglia to clean up the brain most
of the time but what we want to try to
do is to create
an optimized environment so that in the
time when these
new synapses are particularly vulnerable
to rights being engulfed that we've
protected them and and sort of
optimizing that window of plasticity
that's produced by the treatment exactly
and enabling it to persist for for a
longer period of time and you know the
one possible way this could play out but
it's certainly not by by no means the
only possible way would be that maybe
the first time it lasts two weeks and
then maybe when you have repeated
combinations of rapamycin and ketamine
maybe it can last longer and longer from
there which would be really great and it
would be great for for a number of
reasons one is
as we say and we keep coming back to
both of us have tried to make the point
that no treatment no medication is
without risk every medication and
treatment has risk and so we want to
provide a treatment
that has as few exposures to the drug as
possible because that's a way of
limiting risk and it's a way of ensuring
at the same time
increasing the likelihood that people
will stick out the treatment
and it will increase the likelihood that
people will get the treatment because it
will cost less
so systems of care are more likely to
adopt a less expensive treatment
people are likely to take
a treatment that's less burdensome for
them to
take and if we can space out to avoid
that period of time when people are
getting you know the
more frequent infusions we reduce the
cost we increase the safety improve the
tolerability and we provide a greater
flow through the clinics so that more
people can get access to the treatment
so I think at every level if we can if
there is truly a potential to realize
here and if we can realize that
potential then I think a lot of people
could benefit by that let's get to know
ketamine a bit better by doing I don't
want to say side by side comparison but
throwing it in the mix with a lineup
kind of the usual suspect style
and the lineup consists of other
psychedelics and I should just take a
second to say that in my subjective
experience
particularly I don't advise this but at
the doses that sort of push you through
the Looking Glass which I think no one
really needs to do but I consider
ketamine much more of a psychedelic
compound at at higher doses then I do
something like MDMA if we take as
characteristic of psychedelic
experiences at higher doses ego
dissolution
Etc also I wanted to
hearken back to something you mentioned
which was solvent RNA being short
lasting short acting and I just want to
emphasize for anybody out there who's
maybe psychedelic naive or not
experienced that
short acting is is the most relative
term imaginable when applied to
psychedelic experience and I would say
short lasting and Earth time yes but
let's just say if it's in the case of NN
DMT or five Meo DMT only 15 to 20
minutes or 10 to 20 minutes like put
your hand on a hot stove and tell me
only 20 minutes
just not that you'd automatically have a
hot stove experience but it may not and
very frequently will not feel like
uh 20 minutes so to be aware of that but
if we look at
other psychedelics if we put ketamine in
that class for the time being or even
just put ketamine by itself and then
other psychedelics
there seem to be some
not all not totally overlapping but some
similar effects the release of glutamate
activating say mtor affecting mtor bdnf
so brain Drive neurotrophic Factor what
are some of the closest comparables
that you've seen and how are they most
similar and how are they most different
I think you captured the the key point
of convergence which is these are
structurally these drugs are not at all
similar yeah mechanism of action these
drugs are not at all similar
and where they converge
which is you know
something you have to expect in the
brain which is just this enormously
complicated organ
that where they converge is how they
perturb the effects of
micro circuits and micro circuit being a
cluster of a small group of excitatory
and inhibitory cells that are you might
say the transistor if you will of the
transistor radio in other words the
lowest level that has the superordinate
properties that you're
that you can study in relation to
cognitive effects so
when you give a dose Academy you do two
things
mainly three things one is you do
activate inputs to the cortex from the
films
you're really disinhibiting them and
you're you're inhibiting the inhibitory
nerve cells the Gavin nerve cells so
you're locally reducing the degree of
inhibition and you're increasing a
little bit the excitatory input could
you just repeat the effect on the
thalamus and I'll just say this I don't
know if it's the best metaphor again but
is it fair to say the thalamus is a bit
like the traffic cop for sensory inputs
going to the brain it's like a relay
station that through which everything or
most things must pass before going to
the cortex for processing could you just
repeat the effect that ketamine has on
the thalamus so what I'm going to say
about ketamine and the hallucinogens and
the psychedelics if you will
are going to be complementary at each
stage of information processing ketamine
is relieving inhibition in the thalamus
in other words resulting secondarily in
excitation and hallucinogens
psychedelics are stimulating thalamic
neuronal act the output of the thalamic
neurons so you have sensory information
coming in and the ketamine is distorting
that message to the cortex and
psychedelics are creating a new message
and uh similarly in the cortex
ketamine is relieving inhibition and
thereby increasing activation and the
psychedelics are driving
autonomously excitation
essentially again creating a new message
and so that difference has been one of
the reasons that people have thought
that ketamine sensory experiences tend
to be more distortions of sensory
experience
in other words the walls are breathing
in and out my arm is now a foot longer
than it used to be you know things like
that whereas
oh look there's there's
um a shining glowing orb in the middle
of the room that wasn't there previous
you know from the psyched out right a
fully fledged hallucination in that way
they're not exactly the same in terms of
the micro circuit but they both have as
a common property this increase of
excitability increase in glutamate
output triggering the downstream
neurotrophic effects and triggering the
regrowth of the synapses that had been
lost in animal models and so we see
evidence hints of efficacy in the
Imperial College study and in the
studies done at Hopkins and and some of
the other trials and a little bit of a
stronger signal
in the
Compass data that's been released in the
press releases
but we do not yet have
data in the treatment resistant
depressed population and there are a lot
of reasons why we have different
populations being studied for the
different agents but to make a long
story short
even despite all the differences in the
clinical data at the basic science level
we do have this kind of common
effect on on micro circuits and regrowth
of synapses and and that's encouraging
as a potential foundation for the way
people think about the potential
therapeutic effects of of psychedelics
how important is the role of bdnf again
brain derived neurotrophic factor I
think I'm getting that right
to you know put them on again a suit and
gets fancy it's the equivalent of my my
vocab that I use but
how important is bdnf
as far as we know to the increase in
synaptic
or dendritic growth
or synaptic density or
efficiency if at all
there are a whole family of neurotrophic
factors in the brain and when they have
tended to be studied
there has been a story
that when the different neurotrophic
factors have tended to be studied there
has been some
indication that other neurotrophic
factors may also be involved in the
antidepressant effects of ketamine and
psychedelics and in fact the
antidepressant effects of ssris and
other antidepressants
and
one of them
called
Vaso endothelial growth factor rolls off
the tongue it does it's really a
beautiful phrase and that is a nerve
growth factor that or growth factor that
seems to involve the
the
interface of neurons and glia with the
surrounding circulatory system the short
name for it is vegf at least that's what
people call it if you block vegf you can
reduce the antidepressant effects of
most antidepressants just like if you
block bdnf you can block the action of
most antidepressants
but bdnf does seem to be really
important it's a key thing it affects
raising bdnf effects both
the synaptic efficacy and it affects the
synaptic
number and and it affects the synaptic
efficacy
because
what it does one of the things it does
in the Deep potentiated synapses the
less efficient synapses when the bdnf
levels goes up it tends to drive
more receptors for glutamate to the
synaptic surface in other words it tends
to make the
neuron more receptive to glutamate and
so that in in that way
compensating for the earlier deficits
and synaptic efficiency and
and it tends to be involved in the
regrowth of the synapses via the
mechanisms we just talked about you know
that mtor is a part
so I want to mention a few things number
one is if you're listening to this
podcast and you're thinking
I don't think I really want to use
ketamine I'm pretty sure I don't want to
use rapamycin
but man this bdnf stuff sounds pretty
good sounds like it could be beneficial
I would suggest that you explore a few
different types of exercise there's
actually a book that was published quite
a long time ago called spark that goes
into some of the physiological
underpinnings of psychological
or mood Improvement following exercise
and you can go to PubMed
or I spend a
pretty ridiculous amount of time and I
just pulled up one as an example
exercise this is the the the name of the
paper exercise promotes the expression
of brain derived neurotrophic factor of
bdnf through the action of the Ketone
body beta hydroxybutyrate now
this is interesting on a number of
levels this is just the first one I
pulled up this is from 2016. seems to be
pretty decently cited
uh but the the point being that
you feel better often after certain
types of exercise why is that it's not
Magic
in fact it is increasing
one of the let's go you know agents or
factors that we're talking about bdnf
what's interesting about that particular
paper to me also is that and this ties
into some other guests I've had on the
podcast like Dr Dominic D'Agostino
is it raises questions and I'm sure Dom
has an answer for this because this is
what he spends most of his time on but
could exogenous consumption of beta
hydroxybutyrate BHB which is available
there are synthetic versions also
provoke increases in bdnf
actually I have something to show you
John hold on one second let me just grab
it sure
so you might get a kick out of this and
this is before I even mentioned this I
just want to
say this is a a really good case of do
as I say not as I do
but I've always enjoyed drinking
alcohol with friends having a few drinks
here and there I don't I don't think I
have any abusive Behavior with it I mean
maybe in my early 20s I've looked like a
lot of people in their early 20s
probably didn't make the best decisions
but these days
maybe once every week or two I'll have a
few drinks with friends but it
vastly disrupts your sleep architecture
it causes all sorts of sleep issues
in addition to other issues and so I was
looking for potential Alternatives I
rolled out ketamine for all the reasons
that we've spoken about but uh I did
find this which is so if you could see
this it says R1 comma three Ginger mule
hard ketones so so this is r13 butane
dial which is
uh it's an ethanol-free alcohol it's a
ketone that produces some of the I don't
want to say delirium but some of the
effects that you would commonly
associate with alcohol I will say that
it still seems to disrupt sleep if you
consume it too close to bedtime but not
as much at least based on Aura ring data
and so on not as much as ethanol itself
so pretty interesting stuff
I want to use this as a very indirect
Meandering segue to a question about
ketamine are you aware of any impact of
ketamine
on sleep architecture or sleep yeah it
does affect sleep
it's probably one of the ways that
alcohol intoxication at particularly at
high levels affects sleep is by blocking
nmda glutamate receptors and and there
are similar
there's some EEG sleep EG studies
showing reduction in Sleep Quality after
getting
ketamine and
so
when that data was reported there were
some people who thought well maybe the
disruption in sleep is actually
contributing to the antidepressant
response because for so many people the
full anti-depressant response doesn't
really appear until at least one night
of sleep after after Academy but we
don't really know the answer to that yet
just to come back to exercise you know
exercise
shows dose-related antidepressant
effects and my colleague and I actually
analyzed
my colleague led the study Adam chakrude
and this remarkable data about how in a
pretty dose related way increasing
exercise up to
reasonably high levels particularly in
the context of Team exercise can be very
helpful for for depression it is
possible to engage in such extreme
exercise that you lose the protective or
at least some of the protective effects
of of exercise and we don't really know
if that's a product of the exercise or
who is the people who are choosing to
exercise at those very extreme levels
yeah they know the stress that they're
in but but the idea that you say about
raising bdnf and other beneficial
effects of exercise
and the possibility that that would
synergize with
antidepressant treatment which also
raises you know ssris also raise bdnf in
the brain and
s does ketamine and psychedelics
John are there any other
any other pictures you'd like to paint
of possibilities or teasers for things
that you see being explored or that you
yourself would like to explore just uh
forward-looking let's just say within
the next five years
it seems to me that
ketamine along with some of these other
more classically labeled psychedelic
compounds so the tryptamine psychedelics
some phenethyl means but to a lesser
extent you know mescaline would be in
that category
are not just being explored but they're
being taken apart right the car is being
parked in the garage every component is
being removed and for therapeutic
reasons and also for economic reasons
things are being
uh modified repurposed in every which
way possible what are some of the more
interesting Explorations that you are
aware of or that you anticipate seeing
in the next
say within the next five years
so I think within five to ten years the
current generation of
nmda receptor antagonists nmda receptor
subtype antagonist at least the one-site
subtype a selective group called the
nr2b antagonist the r ketamine
and some of the combination therapies
with ketamine I think that that will
settle out and we'll know whether
there's a meat on those bones and
I think in parallel
in the Psychedelic space there are
certain key Concepts that that we're
just getting into
that will that will play out over the
next
five at most ten years before before we
have a good sense of how helpful they
are and probably the best known and in
some ways perhaps the scientifically
strongest Foundation is the idea that
psychedelics can signal
at the same receptor via different
Downstream mechanisms and the work of
Brian Roth
and and David Olson now each of them
have been associated with different
pharmaceutical companies and and other
people
are pursuing this and and the idea is
imagine
you're driving a car and instead of the
car that we're used to it has two gas
pedals
and if you step on one gas pedal maybe
you have uh you drive the electric motor
and if you step on the other gas pedal
you drive the internal combustion engine
and there are situations where you're
driving where it's much better to drive
the internal combustion engine like
there are no charging stations but there
are gas stations and you want to fill up
and we all know about that
charge anxiety that comes with an
electric vehicle but the other gas pedal
gives you Electric
power and that has all kinds of
advantages as well well a receptor is
like that most receptors including the
serotonin 2A receptor which is the
Target in the brain
can signal via two mechanisms one
pathway involves is sometimes called the
traditional pathway or canonical pathway
involves
internal substrates that have names like
cyclic amp or phospholipation different
kinds of signaling mechanisms but
particularly the cyclic amp dependent
pathway and and then the other gas pedal
signals by
a compound called beta arrested
and the idea is that
that different effects are mediated by
these different signaling Pathways and
if you could just selectively step on
one gas pedal as opposed to the other
that maybe you can get the
antidepressant effects of psychedelic
drugs without getting the Psychedelic
effects
so some people
like my friend Roland Griffiths would
say that's the
wrong idea in the first place that the
Psychedelic effects in the context of
embedded in psychotherapy
adds to the intrinsic antidepressant
effect that you would get just by
triggering synaptic growth and doing
things like that and others would say
Well it certainly would be a lot easier
to use these drugs to take them and to
prescribe them if they didn't produce
you know these psychedelic effects well
they could both be true right absolutely
those could both be true and for people
who don't know
uh is it fair to say that you are to
ketamine research what Roland Griffis is
to Modern psilocybin research I mean is
that fair to say yeah Roland has been a
just a tremendous leader in this space
and and one of the very first pioneers
you know there have been a number of
pioneers
people who who names who we've forgotten
who who in their own way pioneered this
science going back to the
1960s people like Daniel Friedman Danny
Friedman and uh you know Sasha shulkin
and Mark Guyer and Dave Nichols and so
on and so on and so on but Roland has
really been instrumental in moving this
work forward
just a wonderful contributor and Pioneer
in the field yeah he's a wonderful human
and I I feel also an impeccable
scientist who's been such a gift to
psychedelic research in part because he
did not begin with psychedelic research
that makes sense I mean he was certainly
at one point considered one of the
foremost experts if not the foremost
expert in caffeine metabolism and has
studied so many different compounds and
has been published so many times prior
to engaging with the space to be clear
when it was still considered career
suicide by and large
it's it's just been wonderful to get to
know people like Roland and yourself and
I've so much enjoyed this conversation
Dr John Crystal thank you so much for
making the time and you are as uh
certainly I mentioned in the intro of
the co-founder and chief scientific
officer of freedom biosciences is
they're a best website or a best way
people can learn more about freedom
biosciences
I'm sure there is
[Laughter]
oh I love it we will put that in the
show notes so this will be a a a teaser
for people who would like the URL we're
going to put it in the show notes as per
usual in addition to links to everything
that we've discussed so all of the terms
all of the resources all the people
syringing from bdnf to Sasha Shogun
there will be a link to everything in
the show notes if you go to tim.blog
podcast and just search uh well
certainly John may be tough but Crystal
will not be tough that is
k-r-y-s-t-a-l and uh John is there
anything else that you would like to say
any closing comments anything that you
would like to
request of
my listening audience or
share with them before we bring this
epic very comprehensive conversation to
a close
well Tim first let me thank you for the
opportunity to chat about this stuff you
know I think ketamine and S ketamine are
really extraordinarily important
treatment advances and depression is so
terrible
that it's really important for people to
know that there's hope out there and and
even if the hope for them doesn't come
from s ketamine or from ketamine there
are still other things that that can be
done and that treatment can be very
helpful and and it's really important to
get connected if you're if you're
struggling and don't give up
the second thing I'd say is I really
appreciate the way that we've talked
about it today these are drugs every
drug has a risk you have to take them
seriously you have to give them the
respect
that they need in terms of making sure
that
if you're exposed to them you're using
them in the right way in a way that
doesn't put you at risk for harm and
a lot of the things we've talked about
are very early stage development ideas
and really not ready to be built into
recreational practice but let me just
say it's been an extraordinary pleasure
to hang out and chat so
I really appreciate the time
absolutely and I I hope we have another
chance like we did after South by
Southwest
some time ago to uh cheers and perhaps
share a glass of my favorite neurotoxin
some type of wine probably or maybe a
gin tonic maybe I'll bring along some
r13 butane dial for you to try but uh
for people who are listening who are
prone to depression or experiencing
depression and want to learn more about
ketamine assisted
treatment options are there any
resources you can recommend
or websites or organizations sure so if
you're interested in the S ketamine and
in ketamine treatment generally Jansen
has a lot of information on their
website about s ketamine this is bravado
is at the trade name right and people
are welcome to to contact we have the
Interventional Psychiatry service at
Yale New Haven Hospital doctors ostroff
and Santa core or my office or
in most cities most universities
nowadays have a ketamine service in a
place where you can get connected so the
availability of ketamine programs is
growing and those are the places that I
know of but I'm sure there's some better
centralized information sources we'll
try to pull a few things together my
team and put them in the show notes as
well and I will just give
yet another a warning cautionary note
which is there are also a lot of
fly-by-night
ketamine operations or ketamine clinics
that really push people through the
system like cattle going through a
cattle Chute and not all clinics or
clinicians are created equal and you may
make certain assumptions about support
and Aftercare that will be misplaced
with certain places so I I do think it's
a great idea to first go to at least
educate yourself with
credible University sources if possible
and I will also speak to a few other
folks and maybe follow up with you and
we'll put things in the show notes for
everyone at tim.blog podcast Crystal
like I said easy to find
k-r-y-s-t-a-l and we will add the link
for freedom biosciences
and John what a pleasure and what a gift
to spend this time with you to learn so
much I have copious notes everywhere and
uh I think that this and I hope that
this will be uh of of great use to
people and as you said in your closing
comments provide some hope perhaps for
those people who may feel hopeless and
helpless certainly I've been there
before and to reiterate what you said
there are tools that can help there are
people who can help so thank you very
much John
take care thanks so much